Hallo, eine Vorschau funzt mich, was ist da kaputt?
Die Mokka ist, ähm, wir machen keine Weep-Musik an jetzt.
Bei der Chat, die ja letztens eskaliert ist, als ich Weep-Musik angemacht habe.
Ja, weiß ich noch.
Ich hab gehofft, du hast es vergessen.
Wie kann man bei so einem Tab-Chaos arbeiten? Ich arbeite ja nicht.
Excellent.
Ich hab nix Spezielles vor.
Ich hab gedacht, ich mach heut mal kein MMO-Kreisel-Crime.
Und ich mach einfach mal den Stream an, wir schwätzen ein bisschen.
Du hast VIP verdient.
Ja, komm, ja, hast du, hast du.
So, du bist der erste VIP, Michael50Billion.
Ich hab zwar keine Ahnung, was das bringt.
Beziehungsweise, ob das irgendwelche, ob man damit irgendwas machen kann.
Das stimmt, du bist schon wirklich lange am Start.
Und das mit dem Emote weiß ich auch noch.
Ich hab gehofft, du hast es eigentlich vergessen.
Was macht das Frankfurter Stonksleben?
Das ist eine gute Frage, was die, also das sind ja zwei Fragen.
Das ist ja einmal, was machen die Stonks?
Das gucke ich jetzt mal nach.
Und danach ist, was geht in Frankfurt so.
Ich hab letztens, mir ist letztens aufgefallen, dass wir in Frankfurt...
Alter, die Stonks gehen ja ab.
Fast 7000 Euro einfach durch nichts machen.
Aber ihr wisst ja, das ist, solange ich den Kram behalte, hab ich ja nur virtuell Geld.
Die Nvidia Stonks gehen massiv.
Ich hab keine Nvidia, wobei, doch, wahrscheinlich hab ich da ein bisschen auch Nvidia Stonks dabei.
Aber das ist ja nur ein ETF.
Also ich hab nicht explizit Nvidia Stonks.
Ich guck mal kurz in meiner App, was die Nvidia Stonks machen.
Warum gehen Nvidia Stonks eigentlich so krass ab?
Hatten die, die hatten irgendeine Konferenz oder sowas, gell?
Ja, okay, die Nvidia Stonks, die gehen wirklich massiv ab.
Ich mein, die sind innerhalb von einem Jahr um 267% gestiegen.
Und innerhalb...
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, sieben Jahren oder so.
Boah, keine Ahnung, 20.000% oder so.
Das geht ja richtig ab.
Nvidia Stonks, Stonks richtig rein gerade.
Ein, ein, World, äh, Moment.
Ich hab einen, das ist nämlich das langweiligste, was man haben kann.
Ich hab ein FTSE All World Accumulating.
Müsst man wieder was, was einkaufen, so.
Nur weil, nichts mal überwiesen.
More Stonks.
Nee.
Ich überweise immer nur unregelmäßig alle paar Monate, dafür ein bisschen mehr.
Big Stonks.
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind, ich mach mal meine VM an und update.
Weil Arch, by the way, da ist auf jeden Fall wieder einiges an Updates aufgelaufen.
Ach ja, was das Frankfurter Stonks-Leben macht.
Pog.
Was das Frankfurter Stonks-Leben macht.
Also, Stonks hab ich dir jetzt gesagt.
In Frankfurt ist mir letztens aufgefallen, dass wir jetzt eine offizielle Waffenverbotszone haben.
In Frankfurt.
Für alle, die es nicht gesehen haben.
Ah, ich vergess, Twitter ist ja nicht usable mehr, gescheit.
Jetzt hier, guck mal.
Also, wir haben jetzt, wir haben jetzt in Frankfurt, bin ich letztens vorbeigelaufen,
hab ich gesehen, eine Waffenverbotszone.
Von 20 bis 5 Uhr.
Ich frag mich ja, in Hamburg, ja, das mag sein, aber hier nicht.
Ich frag mich ja, was ist von 5 bis 20 Uhr?
Gut, ich mein, Waffen sind nie erlaubt.
Kommt aber drauf an, welche.
Da darf gemessert werden, 20 bis 5 Uhr, ja.
Ja, so Sachen wie, wie, irgendwie, Reizgas und so Zeug, das ist ja normalerweise nicht, nicht zwangsläufig verboten.
Also.
Ähm.
Ich hab gelesen auf Twitter, die Leute haben mir das erklärt.
Dass das dazu quasi legitimiert, dass die Polizei auch ohne Verdacht Waffenkontrollen hier durchführen darf in dieser Zeit.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist am Hauptbahnhof.
Also in der Nähe vom Hauptbahnhof.
Auch zu Recht, ja.
Wenn man sich da die Gestalten teilweise anguckt.
Ich hab lange.
Nichts Wildes mehr mitbekommen, am Hauptbahnhof, muss ich sagen.
Also.
In den Nebenstraßen ist mehr los, als am Hauptbahnhof.
Na, in der Nebenstraße hab ich schon Überfall mitbekommen.
Also, nicht, dass irgendwie einer jetzt eine Bank überfallen hätte oder ein Geschäft.
Ich hab mal, ich hab, dann ist es kein Überfall, sondern, da hat einer, einer ausgeraubt auf offener Straße.
Hat die, hat ihr das Zeug geklaut und das abgehauen.
Und das Witzige war, die kannten sich.
Die hat eben den Namen, hat ihm seinen Namen hinterlegt.
Haben hinterhergeschrien.
Ja, da waren schon ganz merkwürdige Sachen.
Aber am Hauptbahnhof selber hab ich schon ewig nichts mehr mitgekriegt.
Es ist auch nicht wirklich gefährlich.
Also, Hauptbahnhof ist, äh, assi und eklig teilweise.
Wow, Hacker-Man steht am Start noch.
Aber Hauptbahnhof ist nicht wirklich gefährlich in dem Sinn, dass man da, ja, das ist nicht irgendwie, wie irgendwelche Slums in Brasilien oder so.
Dass, wenn man da hingeht, dass man Angst haben muss, dass sie gleich die AK rausholen.
Oder dich messern.
Ich hab mal, wann war in Brasilien WM?
Oder Fuss, Fussball, äh, ja, muss WM gewesen sein.
Ist schon, ist schon ein paar Jahre her, gell?
Zumindest hab ich dort mal ein Video gesehen.
2014, ja, das kann sein.
Da hab ich ein Video gesehen.
Da haben die Fußballfans nach einem Spiel einfach mit ihren AKs auf ne, auf ne Betonwand geballert.
So, einfach so, als wär's das normalste von der Welt.
Yeah, Fußball!
AK raus!
Gold!
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam!
Da dachte ich auch, Alter!
Das ist echt komplette, so, Paralleluniversum da.
Da holst du einfach just for fun die AK raus und ballerst ein bisschen rum.
Aber natürlich ne AK-47, was sonst?
Das Ding kann ja weltweit gebaut werden.
Ich hab letztens mal ein Video drüber gesehen, warum das so beliebt ist.
Anscheinend gibt es dort, gibt es keine, keine Lizenzgebühren in dem Sinn.
Und die Pläne sind allgemein bekannt.
Also.
Jeder, der Bock hat auf der Welt, kann ne AK haben.
Kann ne AK-47 erstellen.
Also.
Jeder, der Bock hat und kann, kann das machen.
Darf das machen.
Ja, das hat mich echt bisschen irritiert.
Also, dass die da auf irgendeiner Betonwand geballert haben nach nem Fußballspiel.
Vielleicht war's auch vor nem Fußballspiel, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
So.
Zack.
Ähm, Chatgeber, warum bin ich eigentlich so dumm und hab rebooted, ohne, dass ich alles geupdatet hab?
Richtig Hardcore-Pipiger.
Oh, guck mal.
Ach nee, ich hab gelesen, von 12 auf 13, das ist von 12.2 auf 12.3.
Ja, wie juckt's, man.
Das Fritzbox-Video hat 270k Views.
Ja, kann mir das nicht erklären.
Ich kann mir das schon erklären.
Das ist ein Video, was enorm viele Leute anspricht.
Und man muss ja auch mal sagen, das Thumbnail und der Titel ist schon gut gewählt, ne?
Ja.
Verkauf verboten, das Ende der Fritzbox.
Das ist schon gut gewählt.
Und nach dem Gefühl, jeder zweite in Deutschland ne Fritzbox hat, interessiert das auch viele.
Das ist wirklich gebetet.
Wobei man sagen muss, so gebetet.
Also, manche in den Kommentaren haben ja wirklich gemeint, so, oh, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Naja, zu dem Zeitpunkt, das stimmt, so krass gebetet ist das gar nicht.
Natürlich ist es ein bisschen gebetet.
Aber das war ja wirklich...
...gerade in den News.
Gerade in den News, so, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das Video aufgenommen hab.
Es gab Seiten, die haben geschrieben, oh nein, demnächst werden alle Fritzboxen beschlagnahmt und sowas.
Ja.
Ich hab kein DSL.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Kein DSL, keine DSL-Probleme.
Allerdings hab ich Vodafone, beziehungsweise früher Unity Media.
Ich hab andere Probleme.
Zum Beispiel, wenn der Stream mal wieder nicht geht.
Ah, nochmal rebooten.
Warum?
Weil Reboot immer hilft.
Ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie oft Reboot hilft.
Letztens auf der Arbeit auch...
...war es denn...
...ach, irgendein Java Tomcat Service, glaub ich, war das.
Ne?
Nie was damit zu tun gehabt.
Und...
...ich meine so, ja, ich kenn mich mit dem Service nicht aus, mir fällt da nichts ein.
Wollen wir mal rebooten und gucken, ob er dann wieder geht.
Und was meint ihr, Leute?
Rebootet, bam, geht wieder.
Also, es ist wirklich erschreckend, wie oft Reboot die Antwort auf Probleme ist.
Ich hab euch ja die Story mit dem Kühlschrank schon öfters erzählt.
Recycle-Story.
Ich hatte mal einen Kühlschrank, der hat immer komische Brummgeräusche gemacht.
Und irgendwann wurd's mir zu viel, da hab ich ihn rebooted.
Und dann hat er nicht mehr gebrummt.
Aber er ging noch, also er war dann nicht kaputt oder so.
Ich hab einfach einen Stecker rausgezogen, Stecker wieder reingemacht, dann hat er nicht mehr gebrummt.
Wo ich mir unschlüssig bin, ist, ob er nicht ein paar Tage später wieder angefangen hat.
Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie viel einfach aus und wieder anschalten.
Also an und aus ist natürlich eine blöde Variante, weil dann ist er aus danach.
Du musst aus und anschalten.
Manchmal kommt es auf die Reihenfolge an.
Leute, gest...
...last...
...QuickMuffs, QuickMuffs mit...
...da hab ich mir auch gedacht, okay, ich bin jetzt sicherlich auch nicht der krasseste Kopfrechner.
Aber das wär mir nicht passiert.
Ich hab mit einem auf der Arbeit geredet.
Unterwegs so, da waren wir futtern.
So über Bonuszahlungen, ja.
Und er meinte so, boah, das ist nice.
Demnächst legen die ja wieder fest, wie viel erfolgsabhängiger Bonus und so es gibt.
Und je nachdem, wie viel's da gibt, ich persönlich hab ja alle meine Ziele erfüllt.
Das kommt ja dann noch dabei.
Und nachdem meine Ziele schon so hoch sind,
wird das dann noch mal mehr.
Und der meinte dann so was wie,
ja, also wenn man das ja, guck mal,
wenn man das rechnet, 1,2 mal 1,4 mal 1,3,
dann ist es natürlich umso wichtiger,
umso größer die Zahl vorne ist.
Hab ich auch gehört M.
Nee.
Du kannst es drehen und wenden, wie du willst.
Es macht keinen Unterschied.
Die könnten auch hinten stehen.
Okay, wenn eine Sache hängen geblieben ist, ja.
Also ihr versteht, was der sagen wollte, ne?
Der meinte quasi so,
wenn mein Bonus steht vorne und der ist 1,8
und das, was dann dahinter kommt,
ist natürlich dann wichtiger, weil vorne schon 1,8 steht.
Ja, also das, nee, nee.
Der hat einfach QuickMuffs im Kopf gefällt.
Es ist vollkommen egal, welcher von den drei in welcher Reihenfolge 1,8 hat.
Das Ergebnis ist immer das gleiche.
Hätte er 1,8,
und Erfolgsbonus so quasi versicherungsweit wäre 1,2,
dann ist es egal, ob es umgedreht wäre.
Also wenn er 1,2 und versicherungsweit 1,8 ist,
das würde überhaupt keinen Unterschied machen.
Was muss man bei E3 machen, dass ein zweiter Monitor funktioniert?
Ich glaube, du brauchst bei E3 selber gar nicht viel machen.
Du musst die richtigen Sachen mit x randere einstellen,
falls du x verwendest.
Wovon ich ausgehe, weil E3 geht nur unter x.
Ja, und soll ich dir nochmal was sagen?
2x3 und 3x2,
es ist sogar egal, ob es 2x3x4 oder 4x2x3 ist.
Bosschamp?
Ich finde übrigens toll...
Wisst ihr, wie die Amis Betaigeuze aussprechen?
Das ist äußerst cringe.
Die sagen Beetleshoes.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die da drauf kommen.
Beetleshoes.
Es gibt ja schon seit längerer Zeit die Vermutung,
dass Betaigeuze demnächst explodiert
und wir uns eine Supernova angucken dürfen.
Also, das Ding ist so weit weg,
der ist schon längst explodiert,
wenn er denn zu unseren Lebzeiten explodiert.
Aber ja, das wäre doch cool.
Haben wir was zu gucken.
Das müsste man sogar bei hellem Tag dann sehen.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Habe ich in irgendeinem Video mal gehört.
Du widersprichst.
Welchen der Sachen, die ich gesagt habe?
Ja, habe ich jetzt eigentlich meine Updates alle gemacht?
Ja, gell?
Also hier, für i3, du musst das machen.
Du musst mit X-Render gucken,
dass deine Displays richtig eingestellt sind.
Und das Einzige, was du dann in i3 machen kannst,
ist, dass du einstellst,
wo der Tray-Output sein soll,
auf welchem Monitor.
Der Rest ist egal, also Tray-Output ist das da hinten.
Der Rest ist egal.
Also das musst du sicherstellen.
Du kannst, glaube ich, irgendwie,
findest du das auch,
das habe ich aber nicht eingestellt,
weil ich nur einen Monitor benutze.
Du kannst auch irgendwie einstellen,
welcher Monitor standardmäßig
welchen Workspace drauf haben soll.
Frag mich aber nicht, wie.
Ich habe das, also auf der Arbeit,
auf der alten Arbeit, nicht auf der neuen,
habe ich auch X und i3 verwendet,
mit zwei Monitoren.
Da habe ich einfach so gemacht,
ich habe immer die Maus rüber getrackt
auf meinen großen Monitor,
habe dann da halt alles gestartet.
Das merkt sich i3.
Also wenn du auf den richtigen Monitor gehst mit der Maus
und dort dann was startest,
dann wird es automatisch da gestartet.
Also das Wichtigste ist,
dass du deine X-Settings halt ordentlich eingestellt hast,
sodass der zweite Bildschirm an ist.
Frag mich nicht aus dem Kopf, wie das geht.
Da kannst du dann irgendwie sagen,
Left, Off, Monitor 1, Auflösung,
keine Ahnung, musst du mal gucken.
Ansonsten,
wir können auch A-Randere verwenden,
das hat dann ein GUI dafür.
Ich persönlich bin X-Randere-Enjoyer.
Weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Ich bin durch, es ist wieder Zeit für ein neues Video.
Und zwar, ich weiß auch schon,
ich weiß auch schon, dass den Titel des Videos,
das wird Home Office ist gescheitert,
oder so.
Aber ziemlich sicher was so,
mehr oder weniger in diese Richtung.
Also ich weiß noch nicht hundertprozentig genau,
aber so 90% so in dem Drehwert der Titel sein.
Home Office ist gescheitert,
das ist kein She-Bait.
Dort greife ich was auf,
was ich auf Twitter gefunden habe,
sorry, auf X,
ich muss mich da auch mal dran gewähren,
was ich auf X gefunden habe.
Da hat irgendein CEO von irgendeinem Laden
irgendwie einen Roman geschrieben darüber,
warum Home Office gescheitert ist.
Mittlerweile hat das wieder gelöscht.
Weiß nicht, ob das zu negativ angekommen ist,
oder sowas.
Aber das war halt mal wieder typisches,
Manager Gelabere,
die halt genau das aus einem Blickwinkel gesehen haben.
Und die Probleme damit haben,
wenn sie nicht die ganze Zeit
den Leuten auf dem Bildschirm gucken können.
Was hältst du von Google Certification für IT Support?
Was möchtest du für Google Zertifizierung machen,
die dir eben IT Support was bringt?
Das würde mich jetzt tatsächlich mal interessieren,
was du da im Sinne hast.
Also ich persönlich denke,
dass sie so gut wie fast alle anderen Zertifizierungen
einfach komplett überflüssig sind.
Zertifizierungen sind ein selbsterhaltendes Gelddrucksystem.
Guck dir an, wie das bei Cisco läuft.
Da gibt es die Zertifizierungen,
da gibt es zertifizierte Schulungsleute und alles.
Da haben wir doch mal von Native Web ein Video geguckt.
Das war ziemlich genau auch das,
was ich über Zertifizierungen denke.
Ich traue mich nicht mehr ein Video von ihm anzumachen,
weil der war ja schon ein bisschen stinkig mit mir
und ich will ihn nicht weiter erzürnen.
Dabei gucke ich die Videos privat echt gern.
Was ich ihm getan habe,
ich habe blöde Sprüche gemacht zum Video,
aber ohne, dass ich wusste,
dass er da persönliche Probleme schon früher mit hatte
und sonst hätte ich das überhaupt nicht gemacht.
Ich habe mir nichts dabei gedacht.
Weil ihre PWA nicht auf iOS funktionieren.
Das habe ich auch gelesen,
dass Apple wieder irgendwelche komischen Dinger plant,
dass PWA nicht mehr gehen.
Der Witz ist ja, auf iOS funzen PWA eh schon nicht richtig.
Wobei jetzt mit Web Notification,
wenn sie das endlich hingekriegt haben,
vielleicht halbwegs brauchbar.
Und jetzt erzählen sie irgendwie,
aufgrund von EU-Vorgaben muss das wieder weg.
Apple ist wirklich, was das angeht,
so ein richtiger Kackladen.
Es gab nie PWA auf iOS.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie du es meinst.
Also PWA auf iOS gab es schon,
aber die waren halt sehr Feature beschnitten.
Bin mal gespannt, ob sie das jetzt hinkriegen mit
andere Browser Engines sind auf iOS erlaubt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch nur so der Form halber
und machen tut es am Ende keiner.
Ich finde das nicht geil.
Ich finde immer kacke,
wenn man Freiheiten von seinen Geräten weggenommen bekommt.
Zum Beispiel, dass man keine PWA mehr verwenden kann.
Ich habe aber, wie gesagt,
bevor ich das jetzt abschließend so sage,
ich habe mich damit nicht beschäftigt,
was sie genau vorhaben.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Chrome entwickelt angeblich schon für iOS.
Ja, let's go.
Ein echter Chrome auf iOS wäre nice
und ein echter Firefox,
wobei man ehrlich gesagt sagen muss,
Firefox ist ein geiler Browser.
Ich bin richtig froh, dass es Firefox gibt.
Unter Linux benutze ich nur Firefox,
unter Windows alles Mögliche.
Aber ehrlich gesagt,
ich finde Mobile Firefox Schrott.
Ich kenne das aber auch nur von Android
und immer, wenn ich Android Firefox verwendet habe,
kam ich mir echt verarscht vor.
Das hat sich so kürzer angefühlt immer.
Dann auch ihre teilweise sinnlosen Add-on-Beschränkungen,
dass wieder irgendwas nicht geht.
Aber nachdem ich kein Android Haupt,
also wie sagt man so,
als eines meiner Mengengeräte im Einsatz habe,
bin ich da nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Meine Android Tablets hängen an der Wand
und zeigen eigentlich nur in einem Browser
mein Home Assistant Dashboard an.
Ach, du glaubst nicht, dass du platzt.
Ich habe explodiert.
Lass es uns wissen, wenn es soweit ist.
Hier habe ich nur einen Monitor.
Also das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe zwei Monitore,
aber jeweils einen Monitor an einem Rechner.
Ich habe zwei Monitore.
Ich kann mit der Maus dazwischen hin und her,
aber die Monitore hängen an zwei unterschiedlichen Rechnern.
Ja, den Eindruck habe ich auch gerade bei irgendwelchen
LinkedIn- und Twitter-affinen Managern.
Die dort immer so auf Premium-Manager machen müssen.
So nach dem Motto,
das sind die gleichen Leute,
die noch vor ein paar Jahren erzählt haben,
ihr Vorbild ist Elon Musk
und mussten das jedem erzählen.
Und die hatten dann natürlich auch die Biografie
bei ihm irgendwie auf dem Tisch liegen und so.
Ich weiß nicht,
wer jetzt der angesagte Hype-Manager ist.
Ich glaube,
Elon Musk ist da so ein bisschen
in Ungnade gefallen,
so bei den ganzen Stonks-Leuten,
bei den ganzen Stonks-Leuten.
Bei den ganzen Manager-Leuten
zumindest ein bisschen mehr als früher.
Und weiß nicht,
was die jetzt auf dem Schreibtisch stehen haben.
Also ich weiß noch,
in der alten Firma,
als dort der neue Abteilungsleiter,
oder ne, nicht Abteilungsleiter,
oder doch Abteilungsleiter,
ich weiß nicht, auch scheißegal,
irgendein Management-Typ angefangen hat,
das erste, was ich von dem gehört habe,
ist in irgendeiner Präsentation,
wo er sich vorgestellt hat,
wie ein Vorbild.
Nein,
rein aus Management-Sicht
gibt es da bestimmt schlechtere Vorbilder,
wenn man halt auch
den No-Life,
wie soll man sagen,
den No-Life-Only-Work
High-Performance-Crime
machen will dann vielleicht.
Übrigens, gerade zum Thema Präsentation,
ich weiß Recycle-Story,
aber fällt mir einfach gerade wieder ein,
wisst ihr, was das cringigste war,
was ich je gehört habe von jemand,
bezüglich Präsentation?
Das ist so cringe,
dass es mich schon cringet beim Aussprechen.
Und zwar,
wir hatten mal so eine Präsentation
von einem Azubi,
das war bei mir auf der alten Arbeit,
war das so,
dass die Azubis immer,
so alle paar Monate,
die Teams gewechselt haben,
und dann mussten die so,
mussten die eine Präsentation,
nee, nee, das nicht,
nein, nein, nicht die Shit-Story,
zumindest,
mussten die Azubis das da immer präsentieren,
und da war ich auf so einer Präsentation dabei,
weil halt der Azubi bei uns im Team gewesen ist,
ich mich da halt auch
mit drum gekümmert habe.
So, habe ich in der Präsentation gesessen,
und da war der Azubi fertig,
und ich muss sagen, das war jetzt sehr,
sehr 0815
uninspirierte Präsentation,
aber für so eine Azubi-Vorstellung vollkommen ausreichend.
Ich habe da nie ein großes Ding,
draus gemacht,
das war so ein Pflichtprogramm,
die meisten hatten da keinen Bock drauf,
das wusste ich auch,
ja, alles nice, weiter geht's.
Zumindest,
war da einer,
den habe ich danach auch so gut wie gar nicht mehr gesehen,
auf der alten Arbeit,
zumindest meinte der dann so,
ja, also er hätte da noch ein paar Anmerkungen zur Präsentation,
aber wir unterhalten uns ja hier
auf Meckern auf hohem Niveau,
aber er hätte ja da noch ein paar Anmerkungen,
also man könnte das so und so und so machen,
und wenn er mal,
und das ist jetzt kein Witz,
das cringet mich so,
hier, Dice of Cringe,
brauche ich jetzt mal als Emote, Alter,
und da hat er halt gemeint,
ja, man könnte das so und so und so machen,
und wenn er mal eine richtig gute Präsentation sehen will,
also hat er zu dem Azubi gesagt,
also aus seiner Sicht hat er gesagt,
wenn du mal eine richtig gute Präsentation sehen willst,
da kann ich dir eine schicken,
ich habe mal eine Präsentation angefertigt
über mein Leben.
Was ist mit dir los, Alter?
Was,
wie jetzt, gibt es keine bessere
Präsentationsthemen als dein eigenes
Leben?
Ich meine,
okay, wenn jetzt
irgendein 70-jähriger
Typ seinen TED-Talk hält,
weil der Typ drei Nobelpreise
gewonnen hat oder so, ja, und der macht
eine Präsentation über sein Leben,
okay,
die ist wahrscheinlich sogar ganz spannend,
aber
ein 30-, 35-jähriger,
ich-find-mich-geil
BWL-Management-Typ,
den keine Sau interessiert,
ich habe
eine Präsentation über mein Leben,
Alter, meine Güte,
das ist,
da haben wir uns
Wochen danach noch drüber lustig
gemacht, also
was heißt wir,
der eine, der noch bei mir auf dieser Präsentation
mitgehockt hat,
richtig unangenehm, Leute,
voll angenehm,
ich bewerbe mich gerade auf Physi-Ausbildung,
daher mache ich gerade das Google-Zertifikat
für den Lebenslauf, kostet das nix?
Frage ich nochmal, ob du ein Video
drüber machen kannst, ohne Scheiß,
ich glaube, das wäre der geilste Tag in seinem Leben,
wenn ich mich gefühlt nach acht Jahren
bei dem Typ melde und sage, sag mal,
kannst du mir die Präsentation schicken,
ich würde gerne ein Video drüber machen,
der würde das feiern,
was ist das für schwarze KVM-Magie,
warum?
Der Typ von OpenAI,
da kann ich mir aber nicht merken, wie der heißt,
ist das der?
Ist das der, der rausgeschmissen wurde
und dann zu Microsoft
ist und jetzt weitermacht und so?
Jaja,
das ist er, jaja,
der ist übrigens,
der ist nur ein Jahr jünger als ich,
der sieht aber, finde ich, viel jünger aus,
ich meine, ich sehe jetzt
auch nicht super alt aus,
wieso, dem gehört der Laden,
das ist Arbeit,
ja, ganz ehrlich,
der hat was richtig gemacht,
wenn die Leute so hinter ihm stehen
und ich finde, so muss das sein,
dass, ehrlich gesagt, das ist, finde ich,
was einen guten Manager auszeichnen sollte,
nicht, dass er den Leuten permanent
auf den Sack geht,
sondern, dass er die Leute
quasi zu den bestmöglichen
Ergebnissen
quasi, wie soll man sagen,
führt,
also das Wort liegt hier halt in führen,
und nicht in das, was die meisten
Manager machen bei uns,
sich selbst geil finden
und rumnerven,
ja,
und da sieht man auch, da kommt was gescheites bei raus,
gerade in, sagen wir mal,
in Bereichen, wo es doch
nicht unerheblich um Kreativität
geht, was Softwareentwicklung
ja ist,
Innovation, Kreativität
geht, da ist das sicherlich
die bessere Variante,
da muss ich ja echt
nochmal was sagen,
jetzt, wo ich, dort, wo ich jetzt aktuell
arbeite, ist es wirklich
ein himmelweiter Unterschied
zwischen den Führungskräften dort
und den Führungskräften in meinem letzten Laden,
ja, also die Führungskräfte
in meinem letzten Laden hat man so den Eindruck,
das sind immer die Leute geworden,
die, also
die einzigen, die nicht weggerannt
sind, sind das geworden, so,
aber nicht wirklich die, die dafür
fähig waren, ein paar
Ausnahmen gab's, ja, ein paar Ausnahmen gab's,
will das jetzt nicht alle sagen, aber ein Großteil, ein Großteil
der Führungskräfte dort war komplett
unfähig, und jetzt
in dem Laden, wo ich bin, ist das
tatsächlich besser, ich mein, ich will nicht sagen, dass ich da
ne, alle supergeil und
best ever und so, das sicherlich nicht,
aber du merkst, dass die dort
deutlich besser vorbereitet werden
drauf, das ist nicht so,
ah, ich würd gern Führungskraft werden, und
ja, wenn wir mal Bock haben, dann
bist du's dann, und du,
wenn du nicht bei drei auf dem Baum warst, dann wirst du's auch,
sondern dort haben die tatsächlich
ein Führungskräfteförderungsprogramm, also
kannst schon frühzeitig sagen, ey,
ich würd das gerne machen, da kannst du auch schon ein paar Kurse
besuchen, wo du dann vielleicht auch feststellst, ey,
Mitarbeiterführung, so mit, mit
Verantwortung für Leute im Team
ist dann doch nicht so meins, aber zumindest
werden die Leute dort nicht ins kalte Wasser geschmissen,
und das merkt man auch,
also, gerade
was so Sachen angeht, wie
Konflikte im, im, äh, im
Team, oder
...
richtunggreifend auch einfach hören auf die Leute,
die Ahnung von dem Thema haben,
das ist ja auch was, was viele Manager nicht auf die Reihe
kriegen,
und das find ich bei uns eigentlich ganz gut,
da hab ich bei fast allen Managern bisher
erlebt, dass die eigentlich alle sagen, okay,
sagt mal, wie ihr's für richtig haltet,
und das ist ja eigentlich auch ein guter Ansatz,
natürlich kannst du nicht immer
alles hundertprozentig dann so machen, wie
das jetzt jemand aus der Technik
für richtig hält, aber es ist
gut, da drauf zu hören,
und das nach Möglichkeiten so zu machen, ja.
Wenn ich jetzt
sage, ah ja, gut, ich hätte jetzt gerne
dafür erstmal
250.000 Euro, dass ich das und das machen kann,
dann ist das richtig ordentlich und gut,
ja, dann ist's okay, dann kann er sagen, okay,
tu's nicht auch vielleicht nur mal kleiner, ja, ich versteh,
was du sagst, ja, ich find das auch sinnvoll,
aber das passt grad nicht, können wir das nicht
irgendwie ein bisschen anders machen, also,
das find ich da wirklich sinnvoll, wie die das,
wie die das handhaben. Äh, den kenn ich,
der ist wirklich richtig nice,
den hab ich geguckt,
Chris Hetfield ist, äh, den, den,
habt ihr vielleicht gesehen, das, der war Astronaut,
das ist der, äh, Astronaut,
der in der internationalen
Raumstation mit der Gitarre was vorgespielt hat.
Das Video haben wahrscheinlich viele gesehen.
Den Ted Talk hab ich gehört,
und darf, darf
ich spoilern, was das, was
das, ähm, angsteinflößendste
war für ihn, was er
im Weltall erlebt hat?
Ich spoiler, ich spoiler das, ich spoiler das
einfach mal. Das angsteinflößendste,
was er im Weltraum erlebt hat, ist,
als, ich krieg's nicht mehr hundertprozentig
zusammen, als er
einen Spacewalk
gemacht hat und sein Auge
angefangen hat zu tränen.
Und er hat gesagt,
im Weltall ist es ja nicht so, dass,
ähm, wenn du Wasser im Auge
hast, dass das automatisch runterläuft,
sondern das hat sich im Auge verteilt.
Und er war quasi an nem
Seil im Weltraum und hat auf einmal
nichts mehr gesehen.
Und da hat er gemeint, okay,
das war glaub ich so ziemlich,
das angsteinflößendste,
was es bisher gegeben hat.
Irgendwo im Weltraum sein und nichts mehr sehen.
Er hat dann auch irgendeinen coolen, coolen Schluss,
Schlussfolgerungen da draus gezogen.
Die, die weiß ich aber nicht.
Also der Talk lohnt sich wirklich.
XY Betriebssystem in 2024.
Wieso? Wir sind uns doch alle einig,
dass 2024 das Jahr
des Linux-Desktops wird.
Widerspricht da jemand?
Nee, das ist so. Das haben wir abgemacht hier im Stream.
Und wenn wir das hier abgemacht haben im Stream, dann wird das auch so.
Ach, das Zertifikat kostet was?
Okay. Ich mein,
Zertifikate schaden nix, wenn du sie hast.
Ich persönlich
find's sinnlos, weil das so ein
selbsterhaltenes Gelddruck-Ökosystem ist.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Hab ich nicht.
Ich hatte gestern nen Bug,
dass Chromium, ihr wisst ja,
ich verwende Chrome, Chromium, Firefox.
Chromium wurde von Windows Defender
als Virus erkannt.
Und ich hab gestern meinen Browser geupdatet
und der ist nicht mehr gestartet. Und ich hab mir gedacht, hä?
Was ist jetzt los?
Warum startet mein Browser nicht mehr?
Und wenn man dann in die Logs guckt,
die super krass versteckt sind,
äh, nicht,
Virus wollte ich suchen, ja.
Man muss übrigens hier hinklicken,
für alle, die nicht wissen. Guck mal, man muss hier hinklicken,
da muss man sagen, Protection History.
Und da steht dann der Kram drinnen.
Ja, guck, seht ihr, das war gestern.
Ah ja, und wenn man da draufklickt,
das ist richtig dumm gemacht,
ich klick da jetzt nicht drauf.
Kommt eine Abfrage, ob
an Windows was geändert werden darf.
Sieht dann fast so aus, als will
er es wieder freigeben.
Übrigens, hier sieht man
auch so ein bisschen kleine
Design-Probleme von diesem
ich weiß es nicht,
Flat Design
Fluent UI
wie auch immer dieser Design
Stil in Windows jetzt heißt.
Es ist so
informationsarm.
Ich mein, Thread
blockt.
21.2.18.29
Ist ja schön und gut, aber
wie wäre es mit ein paar Details?
Muss ich das wirklich dafür ausklappen?
Guck, hier habe ich versucht, meinen Browser zu aktualisieren
gestern. Und danach
habe ich die Virensignatur nochmal geupdatet
von Windows Defender, da ging es wieder.
Hyperland kann ich nicht
testen, weil es in der VM nicht ordentlich funktioniert.
Wilder Igel, dankeschön für den
Sub. Pog.
Das ist sehr, sehr
nice.
Nice.
Splixer, dankeschön für den Sub.
Small access point am Start.
Pogu, Leute.
Exzellente Subs...
Subscriptionen.
2024 wird das Jahr des Chromebooks.
Ah ja, ist das so?
Ja, das mag sein.
Aber ich verwende KVM.
Äh, ich verwende VM, werde nicht KVM.
Okay, quit.
Windows 11 erinnert
mich an ein wild zusammengestückeltes
Flickenwerk
an Software.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel,
ich weiß, ich habe es schon hunderttausend Mal
gezeigt, aber mein Lieblingsbeispiel
ist das hier.
Und die Icons hier.
Und dieses Menü, man.
Alter. Und da sind auch
Icons drin, die sind straight aus Windows
1. Warum
der Baum? Ich glaube, das war das...
Ist der Baum nicht das alte Symbol
für Active Directory, Leute?
Ihr seid doch Windows Experts.
Ist das nicht das alte Active Directory Symbol?
So wie es unter Windows NT
mal gewesen ist?
Hast du schon mal Gentoo inszeniert?
Nein, tatsächlich noch nie.
Ja, guck mal hier. 16 Pixel
mal 16 Pixel.
Der Baum ist das alte Logo für Workgroups.
Okay, das kann auch sein, dass ich das durcheinander
bringe. Ich dachte, dass der Baum ist das alte
Logo für Active...
Wahrscheinlich ist das noch PreActive Directory.
Da spricht
ja keiner dagegen, dass sie das Icon mit ausliefern.
Aber muss das in dem Icon Selector
sein und warum sieht...
Das ist in der Tat
echt eine coole Idee,
wen zu nennen als Gentoo oder
Gentoo, wie das manche Leute sagen.
Ich habe übrigens noch eine
weitere Aussprache
von Kubernetes letztens gehört.
Kubernetes.
Kubernetes. Das hatte ich noch nicht.
Ansonsten haben wir ja alles
dabei von Kubernetes, Kubernetes,
Kubernetes...
Kubernetes.
Was hältst du von Gentoo?
Ehrlich gesagt bin ich
nicht der große Fan von Gentoo.
Vom Ansatz her
von Gentoo. Deswegen habe ich es auch noch nie ausprobiert.
Gentoo hat bei mir...
Bei mir habe ich in Gentoo immer
im Hinterkopf von früher noch
diesen Gag, wenn dir unter
Gentoo einer...
Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht, ob...
Denke ich mir zumindest immer. Wenn dir einer unter
Gentoo eine E-Mail schickt und du willst erstmal
den Anhang öffnen, musst du erstmal
3 Stunden OpenOffice kompilieren.
Das Zeug spricht jeder anders aus.
Weiß ich nicht. Was?
Das ist irgendein Wortwitz. Erzähl.
Was macht der?
Was näht der?
Ich auch nicht.
Okay, Chat, ich bin ja froh, dass ihr das checkt.
Ich check's nicht. Sprich es mal aus.
Also wenn ich eine...
Ja, ich weiß was...
Ich weiß wie man...
Den Zusammenhang zu meinem Kubernetes Aussprache
habe ich schon erkannt.
Ich verstehe nicht, was es mit dem Yu-Gi-Oh! Bösewicht
zu tun hat.
Ist der Yu-Gi-Oh! Bösewicht nicht der Pharao...
Nee, Moment, der Pharao ist der Held.
Sorry, jetzt habe ich durcheinander gebracht.
Ach so.
Ist das schlecht, Alter.
Oh Mann.
Ach du Kage, Mann.
Ja.
LoL IQ Stream. Ich glaube, es wird Zeit für eine Runde
Weeb-Musik.
Nee, heute nicht.
Es geht wieder abwärts, Leute.
Ah, Mann.
Ich bin heute wieder Fahrrad gefahren, Leute.
Ich war jetzt zwei Wochen
nicht mehr auf dem Fahrrad.
Und falls ihr mich fragt, warum,
kann ich euch das gar nicht beantworten.
Irgendwie hatte ich keinen Bock.
Ich bin jetzt zwei Wochen nicht gefahren.
Der Grund, warum ich heute wieder fahren wollte,
ist...
Warum ich heute wieder gefahren bin, ist,
weil ich heute Morgen eigentlich meine Runde rennen wollte.
Aber mir hat immer noch das Bein weh getan
vom letzten Mal rennen.
Und deswegen dachte ich mir, ey,
ich mache jetzt wirklich Pause bis Sonntag.
Dann fahre ich eine Runde Fahrrad.
Und das Problem ist,
ich habe es voll übertrieben.
Ich merke es richtig in den Beinen noch.
Ich bin volle Pulle gefahren.
45 Minuten.
Ach so, nein, nein, nein.
Indoor.
Indoor auf dem Trainer gefahren.
Auf meinem Wahoo Kickr
bin ich gefahren.
Was anstrengender,
was mir viel anstrengender vorkommt,
als Outdoor zu fahren.
Zumindest, ich habe es voll übertrieben.
Ich habe gedacht, ey komm, brauchst du ein bisschen Erfolgserlebnis.
Was hast du eigentlich getritzt?
Ich bin im Durchschnitt
175 Watt gefahren über 45 Minuten.
Das ist ungefähr,
wenn man mal wirklich aufrundet,
das ist
2,0 Watt
pro Kilogramm.
Also ich wiege ein bisschen über 90,
eigentlich ein bisschen drunter, aber
ja, also ungefähr 2 Watt
pro Kilogramm.
Doch, 2 Watt pro Kilogramm.
So rum.
Wie, welche Stufe?
Und
ich weiß jetzt,
dass ich das packe über 45 Minuten,
aber
ich merke sowas von in den
Oberschenkeln jetzt immer noch.
Das war ein wenig
übertrieben, gerade nach 14 Tagen
nicht mehr gefahren.
Und wisst ihr, wisst ihr,
was das aller demotivierendste an der Sache ist?
Ich war übelst im Arsch
und dann bin ich aufgestanden,
hab das gecheckt in meiner Garmin App
und meine Garmin App meint,
nee,
Performance Condition minus 2.
Ich bin noch, ich bin noch
nie über 45 Minuten so viel gefahren.
Ich glaube das höchste bisher war, keine Ahnung,
168 oder sowas.
Und Garmin sagt,
nein, Performance Condition
minus 2.
Nee, das musst du bei dem Trainer nicht.
Das geht über, das macht er dynamisch.
Ich
fahre mit einer App,
die nennt sich Swift.
Ist eigentlich die bekannteste App in der Richtung
und die koppelst du mit deinem Trainer.
Ja.
Dieses Teil,
die Wahoo Webseite ist halt auch so ein Kack,
dieses Ding,
nee, das sieht anders aus bei mir.
Oh nein, Moment, das ist der falsche.
Den ganz teuren habe ich nicht.
Hier, den da.
Die koppelst du mit der App
und die App sagt dann,
wie schwergängig der Trainer ist.
Guck hier, machst du dann,
du machst das Hinterrad vom Fahrrad ab
und machst die Kette da drauf.
Naja, zumindest.
Und wenn du dort bei der App dann halt schneller fährst,
dann wird es anstrengender
und wenn du den Berg hoch fährst in der App, dann wird es anstrengender.
Also, 175, warte mal,
45 Minuten.
Das ist jetzt zwar nicht wirklich super krass,
aber ich bin ja auch Einsteiger,
was Fahrrad angeht.
Aber für Einsteiger ist es ganz okay.
Ich müsste mal,
ich müsste mal so einen
FDP-Test machen, diesen 20-minütigen.
High-Performer-Crimeset-Mindset.
Ach ja,
jetzt habe ich das ja ganz vergessen.
Kann das mittlerweile, hat das mittlerweile gescheit,
Mobile-Apps?
To-Do-Listen und Notifications, Mobile?
Also,
ich wollte,
ich wollte ja vorhin was sagen, mein nächstes, also,
das nächste YouTube-Video wird
mit dem Titel sein, Homeoffice ist gescheitert.
Da wollte ich auf einen Post
eingehen, den
ein, irgendein Manager-Dude
auf Twitter gemacht hat,
wo durchaus auch ein paar wahre
Sachen dran sind, wo ich sagen muss, ja,
also, wenn man das aus Manager-Sicht sieht, dann,
ja, ich kann das, kann das schon nachvollziehen,
aber manch andere
Sachen sind halt schon
etwas
tragwürdig. Und auf eine
Sache geht da gar nicht ein,
und das ist, dass ich,
hast du den Post,
nein, der ist mittlerweile gelöscht, ich hab den gescreenshottet
auf dem Handy.
Und eine Sache, die komplett
vergessen wird, ist, und mir geht's jetzt tatsächlich nur
um IT-Berufe,
weil dort ist es ganz extrem,
bei anderen ist das sicherlich auch so, aber mir geht's hauptsächlich um
IT-Berufe, dass sich das
viele Unternehmen schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht
leisten könnten, heute nicht
ein bisschen entgegenkommen zu zeigen, was
Remote Work angeht.
Die finden ja jetzt schon keine Leute. Es ist nicht
jeder Microsoft oder Google
oder Nvidia oder irgendwas, was man kennt.
Die meisten Läden sind irgendwelche
nur nach 15 Klitschen um die Ecke, die
niemand, niemals jemand gehört hat.
Das ist ja auch das, was ich sage, wenn ich mir so
Stellenanzeigen angucke, ja.
Die Stellenanzeigen,
die sind nicht
geschrieben wie
als erstes,
ne, muss ich anders sagen.
Also, die Stellenanzeige ist
zu 99% das,
wo die Leute zum allerersten Mal
in Kontakt mit dem Unternehmen kommen.
Die meisten Leute haben null
gehört von den Unternehmen,
die die Stellenanzeigen schreiben.
Es ist nicht jeder
eine große, bekannte Firma.
Es ist nicht jeder Google oder Microsoft
oder irgendwie eine internationale Bank oder
was auch immer. Die meisten Leute
kennen diese Unternehmen nicht und das erste,
mit denen sie in Kontakt kommen, ist die Stellenanzeige.
Und daraufhin sind
viele Stellenanzeigen, also
95% der Stellenanzeigen immer noch
nicht optimiert.
Die sind einfach
uninspiriertes
Corporate bla bla.
Dabei ist es bei Stellenanzeigen
genau das gleiche
wie bei Bewerbungen. Das ist das erste,
womit ein potenzieller
Bewerber in Kontakt
kommt.
Und umgedreht ist die Bewerbung das erste,
womit die Firma mit dem Bewerber in Kontakt kommt.
Das muss dementsprechend geschrieben sein.
Die meisten Stellenanzeigen sind einfach schlecht.
Und was ich sagen wollte,
viele Unternehmen, gerade in der IT,
die nicht Microsoft oder Google
oder irgendwas Großes bekannt sind,
können sich das auch gar nicht leisten.
In Berufen, wo das möglich ist,
oder gerade in der IT, wo das möglich ist,
zu sagen, oh nee, Remote Work machen wir nicht.
Die kriegen jetzt schon keine Leute.
Dann sagen die Leute,
dann fange ich halt nicht bei euch an.
Darf ich dir eine aktuelle senden?
Klar.
Ich muss mir da noch ein paar Notizen zu machen,
dass das auch alles ein bisschen stichhaltig ist,
was ich sage.
Man benötigt mehr
Managementkapazität,
um Mitarbeiter im Homeoffice
zu steuern.
Da kann man sich
sicherlich drüber streiten,
je nach Blickwinkel.
Ich würde sagen, wenn man gescheite Mitarbeiter
hat und auch seinen Mitarbeitern
traut, dass sie
ihren Job ordentlich erledigen,
dann liegt das
eher daran, dass viele
Manager das Gefühl haben,
sie sind nicht mehr Herr der Lage
und erkennen,
dass ihr Job in vielen Stellen
gar nicht erforderlich ist.
Das sehe ich
null so, dass du mehr
Managementkapazitäten brauchst.
Vor allem, warum?
Chainlore, bist du so jung noch?
Du hast doch letztens
erzählt,
du erzählst
einen Blödsinn wieder.
Du hast doch letztens
erzählt, du bist jetzt Azubi
in der gleichen
Firma, wo der Noel arbeitet.
Wie passt das zusammen?
Das musst du mir jetzt mal erklären.
Exposed.
Der cosplayt als Schüler.
Also, wenn es nach
geht, ist es sehr beliebt,
dort mit Schüleruniform zu cosplayen.
Ach, Bewerbung angenommen,
mach jetzt mein Abi fertig und dann arbeiten.
Ach so.
Und was ist, wenn du dein Abi nicht schaffst, nehmen sie dich
dann trotzdem? Weil dann könntest du jetzt ja
sagen, scheiß drauf, ich mach gar nichts mehr.
Ist da irgendeine
Klausel drin, dass wenn du das Abi nicht
schaffst, dass es nichts wird?
Join.com, es gibt so viele dieser
Seiten, ey, da hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
Mein Auge,
mein Auge, mein Auge. Ja.
Zumindest, und dann stehen da noch so
Dinger drin, also, das erste,
diesen ersten Punkt, wie gesagt, das hat insgesamt sieben Punkte
oder so, der Postfilm, das erste, was ich gesagt
hab, das ist natürlich sehr einseitig aus meiner Sicht
jetzt, es mag sicherlich
Abteilungen und Leute geben, wo man
mehr Management-Kapazitäten braucht,
wenn die im Homeoffice sind oder
sonst wie, aber einen Punkt
muss ich jetzt schon sagen, da steht dann, steht noch viel mehr drin,
aber eine Sache ist auch noch, die er schreibt
hier, im Homeoffice
optimieren sich viele Mitarbeiter
dahingehend, ein
Ergebnis-Arbeitspendel, um so angenehm wie
möglich zu erledigen. Besser ist
die Optimierung, in einer gegebenen
Zeit den Output zu maximieren.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding,
da sind nicht die Schulter
Mitarbeiter.
Wenn die Mitarbeiter ihre Ziele erreichen,
ist das doch vollkommen legitim,
zu sagen, jawoll,
ich hab meine Aufgaben erledigt
und gut ist.
Also, das deckt sich
überhaupt nicht. Und mal ganz davon
abgesehen,
zeugt das von schlechtem
Projektmanagement,
wenn man Ziele nicht
richtig steckt.
Also, ich weiß,
ich hab nicht das High-Performer-
Mindset für sowas.
Mal angenommen, es gibt eine Planung
und da heißt es so nach dem Motto, okay,
wir haben die und die Tasks
und ich sag, hey,
oder sagen wir mal so, irgendeiner sagt hier,
der Max, der macht diese Woche diesen Task
und ich schaffe
den Task, sagen wir mal, am Donnerstag
schon fertig zu haben
und dementsprechend
kann ich dann am Freitag
mich vielleicht um andere Sachen kümmern
oder aber, was ja oftmals
auch hinten runter fällt,
die Sachen, die ich erledigt habe, nochmal ein bisschen
überdenken und vielleicht noch ein paar Sachen
anpassen und ordentlicher machen,
was dann auch wieder der gesamten Sache zugute
kommt, was sich vielleicht nicht in
irgendwelchen Big-Stonks-Management-Zahlen
widerspiegelt, aber unterm Strich das bessere
Produkt gibt,
passt also irgendwie nicht.
Und das nächste, was er geschrieben hat hier,
da muss ich sagen,
das deckt sich überhaupt
gar nicht mit meiner Erfahrung.
Da schreibt er hier,
kurze Abstimmungs-Calls, die den Blick
über die Schulter im Büro ersetzen, sind
im Homeoffice nur schwer möglich.
Viele Leute labern gerne über Gott
und die Welt. Also,
da müssen sich die Management-Leute erstmal
entscheiden, was sie
jetzt wollen. Auf der einen Seite wird
immer gesagt,
oh, im Homeoffice muss man aufpassen,
dass die Leute
nicht vereinsamen
und das ist ja auch unsere Aufgabe
und Homeoffice ist gefährlich und sonst wie was.
Also wollen sie ja, dass die Leute ein bisschen
schwätzen und über Gott und die Welt reden,
weil ja sonst ja der Team-Spirit nicht stimmt.
Ich rede auch ab und zu über Gott
und die Welt, aber meistens
interessiert es mich nicht so sonderlich großartig.
Aber zumindest,
kurze Abstimmungs-Calls
ersetzen nicht den Blick über die Schulter
im Büro. Also ganz ehrlich,
ich finde es viel
einfacher, seitdem
es dauerhaft Homeoffice gibt,
zumindest seit den letzten paar Jahren,
ich finde es viel einfacher,
mit Leuten was abzustimmen, wenn beide
Homeoffice haben über Teams als
vor Ort. Vor Ort hast du immer irgendwas.
Der Typ sitzt gerade in irgendeinem
Meeting, der hat irgendeinen Typ am Platz
stehen, der ist gerade am Telefonieren,
der ist gerade in der Küche, der ist gerade
am Fuddern, der ist gerade kacken,
was auch immer. Ich habe es auf der alten Arbeit
schon gehabt, dass ich dreimal
zu jemandem hingegangen bin und der war
nie da. Homeoffice ist das
easy, wenn du jemanden
hast, der da mitmacht. Dem schreibst
du was in Teams und wenn er in einem Meeting
sitzt, wo er gerade Däumchen
dreht, weil wieder Gott und die Welt
auf das Meeting eingeladen wurden, antwortet
er dir sogar während dem Meeting,
weil es ihm da langweilig ist.
Und kurze Abstimmungs-Calls über Teams
ist viel einfacher
als im Büro, viel einfacher.
Und du hast das ganze Geschwätze und
Telefoniere nicht mit den anderen Leuten im Büro
viel einfacher über Teams.
Das deckt sich absolut gar nicht mit
meinen Erfahrungen.
Und
ich
würde ja gar nichts
darüber sagen, wenn das
jemand auf Twitter postet, so als seine
Meinung. Ist ja auch vollkommen legitim,
dass man das aus Managementsicht
anders sieht, wie ich zum Beispiel.
Aber, was mich ein wenig getriggert
hat an diesem Post, und wie gesagt, der Post ist mittlerweile
auch gelöscht, aber warum ich dazu
mal was sagen will, ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob ich erwähnen soll,
wer es gepostet hat, ist eigentlich egal, falls
derjenige das sieht und das will, ist auch okay.
Aber was mich ein bisschen getriggert
hat ist,
also das sind insgesamt 7 Punkte gewesen,
und einige Sachen kann ich
nachvollziehen, andere weniger,
andere, muss ich sagen, deckt sich
null mit meinen Erfahrungen. Was mich ein bisschen
getriggert hat, ist der letzte Absatz.
Und zwar, unten drunter
stand dann, Fazit.
Die obigen Punkte
stellen keine Meinung dar,
sondern es sind Tatsachen.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, also,
bis zu dem Punkt
hätte ich ja noch mitgehen können, dass das
ein Manager, gerade in dieser Firma, und je nachdem für welche
Teams dazu, noch anders sieht.
Aber eindeutig
quasi so
Aussagen rauskommen und dann drunter schreiben,
das ist übrigens nicht meine Meinung, das ist
Fakt.
Da muss ich was
auch
zu sagen.
Ich mein, meine Meinung ist im
Stream hier, ist die auch Fakt.
Und ich hab dem Chat ja schon oft genug gezeigt,
dass er falsch liegt.
Zum Beispiel, dass Office 365
jetzt Microsoft 365 heißt.
Ja.
Übrigens,
der letzte Satz ist auch geil in diesem Post.
Der letzte Satz ist auch geil.
Die obigen Punkte
gelten für den Durchschnittsmitarbeiter.
Mit High Performer
lässt sich auch im Home Office
gut zusammenarbeiten.
Da musste nochmal das High Performer Wort rein, ey.
Vielleicht bin ich ja
High Performer.
Weil bei mir Home Office so gut funktioniert.
High Performer Mindset am Start.
Naja.
Da muss ich mich mal zu auslassen.
Kann Notion
To Do Listen und
Notifications, Mobile Notifications
Vielleicht soll ich das...
Ja, wirklich? Okay.
Und man kann da auch
Also das ist auch
Text only, oder?
Und man kann das syncen über irgendwas, was man syncen will.
Ohne, dass man den in den Service verwenden muss.
Ja, ich auch.
Hast du das gesehen?
Moment.
Okay, vergesst die Tanne
holt mich... Ah Junge, was mache
mache in ihren...
Was manche in ihren Stellen beschreiben.
Last but not least.
Natürlich haben wir 30 Tage Urlaub.
Ja gut, das hat so gut wie jeder.
Eine attraktive Vergütung sowie Sozialleistung
ein Tip Top Kantine. Ja.
In der wir ab und an auch Produkte
aus eigener Herstellung anbieten. Und zu Weihnachten gibt's
ne Tanne.
Ist doch... Ja und?
Ja und? Was ist da dran so schlecht?
Kantine im Haus ist mega nice.
Find ich jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Warum, was ist da dran so schlimm?
Die Tanne?
Ja, wenn ich keine Tanne will, kriege ich bestimmt auch keine Tanne.
War das jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Mir doch egal.
Soll ich da ne Tanne hinstellen?
Achso, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass die mir ne Tanne sponsern
zu jedem Weihnachten für daheim.
Dann habe ich das falsch verstanden.
Ich dachte, ich kriege ne Tanne gesponsert
jedes Jahr. Sauerei.
Ich habe auch nur 24 Tage
Urlaub, Leute.
Nicht 30. Liegt aber auch daran,
dass ich nur 80% arbeite.
Was nicht Sätge ist, sondern Pog.
Ich muss ein Grinch Recruiter
exposen, willst du sehen?
Ja, aber anonymisiert, please.
Hallo, du hast ja
viel im Bereich DevOps gearbeitet.
Ich habe im Bereich DevOps schon gearbeitet,
also bevor das dann auch bei mir so hieß,
noch bevor es den Namen gab.
Später hatte ich es dann
auch auf dem Zettel stehen, aber das hieß noch gar nicht so.
Als ich angefangen habe
mit Serverautomatisierung und
das Ganze auch über Git verwaltet
und automatisches Ausrollen
und sowas, da gab es das Wort noch gar nicht.
Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen,
ich habe DevOps erfunden oder so,
aber wir haben das schon gemacht
zu Zeiten, da gab es das Wort noch nicht.
Also,
Hallo, du hast ja viel im DevOps-Bereich gearbeitet.
Wie würdest du es machen, dass auf
Remote-Servern das neue
Software-Version als Docker-Container
startet über eine SSH-Verbindung?
Nutzen Jenkins
und muss mich, hä?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt,
was ich meine mit synchen,
dass ich nicht meine Sachen ins Internet
laden muss.
Ich will meine Notizen nicht im Internet
haben bei irgendeinem Service, sondern bei mir
selbst lokal.
Ob das jetzt über Files geht oder ob
in eine Sync-ARP, die ich installieren muss
oder so, ist mir eigentlich wurscht.
Okay, was willst du machen?
Ich muss das mal kurz schenken.
Dass auf Remote-Servern das neue Software
als Docker-Container startet?
Ach, ihr habt eure Produktiv-Software
mit Docker
auf Linux-Servern laufen,
oder wie?
Gut, da muss ich jetzt das Obligatorische
sagen, dass Docker eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht ist.
Dass Docker auch selbst
aber ich weiß, das machen
einige, ich habe das, ich habe da auch
Sachen im Docker-Container am Laufen.
Ich habe letztens einen Teamspeak-Server
im Docker gestartet, Leute.
Teamspeak. Also verstehe ich
das richtig?
Ihr habt irgendwo einen Linux-Server
und darauf läuft eine produktive Anwendung
in einem Docker-Container.
Oder in einem Container, den ihr mit
Docker managt. Und ihr wollt jetzt
ein neues Image bauen und
dass es automatisch gepusht wird.
Also dass es dann
automatisch neu gestartet wird.
Also wirklich,
so richtig schöne Sachen gibt es
dafür nicht. Da muss man immer ein bisschen basteln.
Weil halt wie gesagt, Docker nicht dafür
gedacht ist.
Was wahrscheinlich eines der Aufhänge-
Punkte war, warum es heutzutage sowas
wie Kubernetes gibt. Aber bei Kubernetes
hast du ja auch das ähnliche Problem. Kubernetes
selbst updatet
ja auch keine Images.
So. Einfach von sich
aus, weil es jetzt Bock hat und startet die Pots
neu. Du brauchst da auch was.
Glücklicherweise gibt es
so Sachen wie ArgoCD zum Beispiel, für
Kubernetes. Wo das dann
deutlich angenehmer ist. Also
ich würde es einfach halten.
Ich würde es einfach halten.
Ich würde es folgendermaßen machen. Zumindest ist
es das erste, was mir so aus dem
Stehgreif
einfällt. Mach ein Docker-Compose-File
und check das ein in irgendeinem Git-Repo.
Warte mal, ich muss gerade mal lesen.
Über Jenkins wird ein neues Docker-Image
gebaut und dann auf Nexus deployed. Ah!
Java-Enjoyer.
Das neue Image soll dann auf mehrere Server gestartet
werden. Ja.
Ich würde zwei Schritte machen.
Ich würde zwei Schritte machen. Ich würde ein
eine Build-Pipeline
bauen, die das
wie
keine Ahnung, die die Anwendung
kompiliert und das Container-Image baut und das Container-Image
in die Registry pusht.
Und dann würde ich
also quasi eine
Integration-Pipeline, wenn man so will,
und eine Delivery-Pipeline. Ich würde zwei Jobs
machen. Das erste baut das
Container-Image, pusht das Ganze in das Repo.
Dann würde ich einen zweiten Job machen,
der, oder eventuell,
ich weiß nicht, wie automatisiert ihr das machen
wollt, das Ganze über ein Docker-Compose-File
deployt. Das Docker-Compose-File muss
aber angepasst werden. Weil
du könntest natürlich immer Latest reinschreiben
und sagen hier Force neu deployen.
Aber da hat man
ein bisschen wenig Kontrolle drüber, was dann letztendlich
ausgeführt wird. Also ich find's immer schön, wenn man
auch in der Git-History sieht, okay,
jetzt wurde wirklich infrastrukturseitig
die Image-Version
geändert. Das würde ich auch
bei allen möglichen Kubernetes-Sachen empfehlen.
Latest reinschreiben kann man
zum Testen mal machen. Später finde
ich's sinnvoller, wenn man
den Versionstext reinschreibt. Da kann man nämlich
auch besser nachvollziehen, so nach dem Motto, was läuft
denn da gerade drauf? Und ist
das denn auch das Neueste wirklich?
Wann haben wir zuletzt gepult?
Also, wenn du sonst nichts hast,
mach ein Docker-Compose-File,
starte den Kram über Docker-Compose,
check das File
in den Git-Repo ein,
irgendjemand geht dann hin,
erhöht die
Versionsnummer,
daraufhin läuft die Pipeline los,
die das Docker-File PSSH,
das Docker-Compose-File dahin
deployt, PSSH und
ein, boah fragt mich aus dem Kopf
nicht, wie das funktioniert, ein
Docker-Compose
Recreate oder irgendwie sowas
macht. Schon ne ganze Weile her,
wo ich das mal zuletzt
was in der Richtung gemacht hab.
Ich glaub Docker-Compose
Recreate oder Docker-Compose,
da gibt's ne Option für,
dann stoppt der alle Container und
erstellt die neu.
Ne, ne, ne, nicht ab minus D,
ab minus D ist einfach starten
im Hintergrund.
Du willst,
das Docker-Compose-File ist statisch,
ne, das Docker-Compose-File, ja genau
das mein ich, force recreate, glaub das ist
das, was ich meine. Das Docker-Compose-File
sollte nicht statisch sein, das Docker-Compose-File
sollte die Imageversion eingetragen werden.
Der erste Pipeline-Schritt
baut euer,
baut eure Anwendung,
baut das Container-Image,
pusht das Container-Image in die
Container-Registry.
Wenn
das durch ist und das
im Test getestet ist und in
irgendwo anders ausprobiert wurde
und alles gut ist,
dann trägt irgendjemand in das
Brot Docker-Compose-File
die neue Versionsnummer ein.
Das pusht er dann
also checkt er ein, hier,
shit commit, pusht das
und auf diesen Push darauf
triggert irgendeine weitere Pipeline
oder vielleicht auf den
Merch-Request hin, wie auch immer ihr das machen wollt,
triggert eine weitere Pipeline
und die
nimmt das neue Docker-Compose-File
und ja, schiebt es dann
per SSH auf den Server und macht einen Docker-Compose-
recreate.
Das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert auch relativ zuverlässig.
Also wenn ich es mit Docker machen müsste, dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich
so machen. Da hast du mehrere Vorteile.
Du hast einmal so den
Image-Bild-Prozess und Software
ja, Software-
Kompilierung, so ein Image-Bild-Prozess
in einer Pipeline
und die ganze
Administration, Operation
Sache nachvollziehbar in einer anderen
Pipeline. Das finde ich schon mal sinnvoll,
weil da muss immer noch jemand den Schritt machen
jetzt ist es soweit,
ich will jetzt deployen.
Ich finde das nicht verkehrt.
Irgendjemand muss sagen, okay, jawoll, es ist jetzt
eingetestet, ich will jetzt
die Image-Version von 2.1
auf 2.2
und auf den Push kannst du ja dann reagieren.
Ich meine, du kannst den zweiten Schritt
auch automatisch machen. Du kannst ja in
Jenkins auch ein Docker-Compose-File
updaten lassen, wenn du das wirklich in einer
Pipeline machen willst. Du kannst ja auch
sagen, ey, tragen das Docker-Compose-File die neue
Version ein und dann macht das über
SSH.
Hat dir das jetzt irgendwas gebracht?
Also du kannst das auch ohne Problem
in eine Pipeline machen, das funktioniert schon.
Aber ich finde wichtig, dass
die Image-Version nicht Latest ist,
weil ansonsten hast du das Ding, okay,
da musst du dann erstmal gucken,
okay, habe ich jetzt gepullt, da musst du in Logs
irgendwie nachgucken, stimmt der Hash vom Image
überein, ist das jetzt auch das Richtige und sowas.
Also ich finde es auch wichtig, dass es
nachvollziehbar ist,
wann dort
die Version hochgezählt wurde.
Ich finde es sinnig, wenn man solche
Software-Erstellungs-, Image-Erstellungs-
und eigentliche Operation, Anwendungsdeployment
Sachen ein bisschen trennt,
aber ansonsten Docker-Compose-File
Recreate gib ihm.
Was schöneres fällt mir dazu ehrlich
gesagt nicht ein.
In Kubernetes könntest du sowas mit
Argo-CD machen, das wäre extremely
pog und da sieht man übrigens auch den
Vorteil, das muss ich jetzt an der Stelle nochmal sehen,
da würde man auch den Vorteil sehen von zwei
unterschiedlichen Pipelines, weil
da würde das nämlich genauso
laufen. Die erste Pipeline
baut das Image und
die zweite
updatet quasi das Infrastruktur-Repo,
wo gegen Argo-CD
synct und dann das Neue auf dem Kubernetes
Cluster automatisch ausrollt.
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Ok, Moment, ich guck mir das
Bild an. Wieso ist Docker nicht
geeignet?
Unter anderem aus den Workaround-Sachen,
die ich gerade erzählt habe.
Docker kannst du wunderbar verwenden,
vielleicht muss ich das ein bisschen relativieren,
du kannst Docker verwenden, aber nicht,
wie man so schön sagt, at scale.
Also wenn du zwei, drei produktive Server hast,
da ab und zu mal deine Anwendung updatest,
dich von Hand-PSSH einloggst,
das alles runterfährst,
die Image-Version updatest, das
wieder hochfährst, ist das überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber umso größer
das Ganze wird, umso automatischer das alles
laufen soll, umso unangenehmer wird das
mit Docker. Außerdem ist bei Docker
noch ein paar Sachen drum herum ein bisschen
schwierig, das ganze Netzwerk-Handling
ist zum Beispiel bei Docker auch so ein Ding.
Docker geht ja prinzipiell
an IP-Tables vorbei, beziehungsweise
stimmt so nicht, legt eigene Tables an,
also geht an den meisten Zeug vorbei,
was dann wieder extra Aufwand für
Firewall-Regeln bedeutet, wo du
ein bisschen Gedanken machen musst.
Also man merkt Docker an allen Ecken und Enden an,
dass es eigentlich ein Tool ist, was dazu
gedacht ist, um den Entwicklungs-
und Software-Entstehungsprozess
zu
unterstützen und zu vereinfachen.
Docker ist hauptsächlich
dafür geschaffen worden, wobei ich mich jetzt
da weit aus dem Fenster lehne,
ich kann euch da kein Zitat dazu
sagen, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das
eines der, genannt wurde
als eines der Gründe, warum Docker
geschaffen wurde.
Eines der Hauptgründe, warum Docker entstanden ist, ist,
um dieses, es funktioniert auf meinem
PC-Problem zu lösen.
Du hast irgendwas,
probierst es aus, es funktioniert,
auf deinem Entwickler-Rechner,
du probierst es woanders aus, es geht
nicht. Ein anderer Entwickler probiert es bei sich aus,
es geht nicht. Und das war
eines der Hintergedanken,
was Docker angeht.
Dass es nicht mehr dieses, oh, es geht auf meinem PC,
aber sonst nirgendwo
Problem so oft gibt.
Also eigentlich eher was, was man im
Entstehungsprozess für eine Software verwendet,
weniger jetzt, um sie live zu betreiben.
Kann man aber auch machen.
Ich hab irgendwas übersehen, oder?
Nee. Irgendwann noch was von
Quereinstieg, ah ja. Hey Max, du als
Kenner der, du als
Branchenkenner, ja so der krasse
Kenner bin ich auch nicht, muss ich ja mal
dazu sagen. Ich meine, ich arbeite in Frankfurt
in der Finanzbranche, ich hab letztens
den Job gewechselt, das heißt, ich muss mich zwangsläufig
mit ein paar Sachen beschäftigen,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als
arbeite ich in irgendeiner
Beraterfirma, die jede Woche einen anderen Laden
sieht, oder so.
Also, welche Möglichkeiten fallen dir
ein für einen Quereinstieg in die IT-Branche?
Also,
da muss man prinzipiell sagen, dass es aus
meiner Sicht zumindest aktuell so einfach wie noch
nie zuvor war, quer einzusteigen, wenn man dann
auch ein bisschen was kann, was die Leute haben wollen.
Du musst dir erstmal überlegen,
was der Bereich
ist, auf den du Bock hast,
weil es hat ja keinen Sinn, wenn ich sage,
als Kobol-Programmierer hast du gute Chancen,
du willst dich bestimmt nicht mit Kobol
auseinandersetzen, als so ein Beispiel.
Also, ich will erstmal überlegen,
gerade als Quereinsteiger, was ist denn das, was mir
gefällt, was kann ich denn gut,
was ist vielleicht
was, was ich lernen will,
weil ohne,
wie soll man sagen,
ja, also ein bisschen eigen getriebene
Motivation ist halt
das Lernen auch schwierig.
Und am
motiviertesten, was zu lernen ist,
ist man, wenn man sich selbst dafür interessiert.
Okay, warte mal hier,
ich muss das Bild mal aufmachen.
Wo war das gepostet?
Was ist das?
Moment, das ist das
Terminal, was ein Account braucht,
zum Benutzen, oder?
Das benutze ich nicht.
Ist das nicht das, wo man sich einloggen muss,
damit man das Terminal benutzen kann?
Ne, ne, ne, das könnt ihr knicken.
Ähm,
Sgt. Silver, der
der Link findest
nicht.
Ach hier, jetzt hast du es nochmal gepostet, okay.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, du hast
Okay, ja, das kann
ich zeigen. Okay, LinkedIn
Recruiter am Start, Sgt. Silver
möchte recruited werden.
Beziehungsweise er versucht, ihn zu
recruiten. Also, wen haben wir denn hier?
Fabian L. ist am Start.
Das ist so ein typisches, so ein typisches
Business Recruiter Image, Alter.
Wahrscheinlich auch von
thispersondoesnotexist.com
Achso.
Ich glaube, ich habe alles.
Ja, habe ich ja auch gesagt, dass das
nichts dagegen spricht.
Ich habe auch, wie gesagt, ich habe
letztens sogar ein Teamspeak laufen gehabt im
Docker-Container. Live
und produktiv für drei Leute.
Meinung zur Azubi-Stelle, kann man sich klar angucken.
Okay, zeigt mal ja.
Recruiter, Sgt. Silver wird recruited.
Senior SAP
Systemadministrator.
Oh, das muss aber Fettstocks
geben, oder?
Ein Senior Administrator und
SAP. Das sind ja zwei Sachen,
die schon mal Geld schreien. Also SAP
mehr als Senior Administrator, aber SAP
sehr geehrter
Herr Sgt. Silver.
Ja, das war auch
sie persönlich auf die unten
skizzierte Position.
Die Bank hat den beauftragt,
dich persönlich, na klar.
Die Bank hat dich beauftragt,
mal random Leute anzuschreiben in der
Hoffnung des Funds.
Uns wurden dazu konkret fünf Personen
genannt, die für uns unsere Auftraggeber
im Leben nicht.
Im Leben nicht.
Er hat einfach irgendwelche Leute
angeschrieben in der Hoffnung, er kann
irgendeine Profession absahnen, Mann.
Okay.
Bitte um eine kurze Info, unter welchem Namen
ich sie erreiche. Details, Anforderungen,
ich finde das geil,
dass der gar nicht in Erwägung
zieht, dass du keinen Bock da drauf hast.
Die Dinger sind immer so geschrieben,
wie es gibt keinen Exit-Punkt.
Normalerweise würde ich erwarten, dass
da sowas drinsteht.
Melden Sie sich doch, falls Interesse besteht
oder bei Interesse
können wir uns in kommende Woche, aber
nein, da gibt es kein
If Return drin
in diesen Texten immer.
Okay.
Bitte um eine kurze Info, unter welchem Namen
ich sie erreiche. Details,
Anforderungen, Inhalte besprechen wir direkt
telefonisch.
Es existiert
gar nicht die Möglichkeit, dass du keinen Bock
da drauf hast.
Okay. Können wir bitte in den kommenden
Wochen Dienstag oder Mittwoch jeweils
Mittag oder Nachmittags miteinander telefonieren?
Wir benötigen im ersten Schritt
ca. 20-25 Minuten. Okay.
Du wirst
Senior SAP System Administrator,
Berichtsweg
Leiter System
Administration, was auch immer das
bedeuten soll. Was ist denn ein Berichtsweg?
Ist das der, dein
Chef oder was?
Ist das quasi, da wo
du hin reportest quasi?
Ich wusste, ich habe das noch nie unter
Berichtsweg gesehen.
Also auf gut Deutsch
dein Chef ist der Leiter System
Administration. Arbeitgeber,
der Kolonie gehört,
Gehalt 80-90
K. Das muss nicht schlecht sein.
Je nach
Region. Ich meine, das ist SAP.
Benefits
unter anderem hybrides Arbeitsmodell,
flexible Arbeitszeiten,
Freizeitausgleich, Betriebsrestaurant,
Fitnessangebote.
Mein alter Chef
hat erzählt, also in der alten Firma, wo ich
gearbeitet habe, der hat mir erzählt,
die haben ein
Problem Leute zu finden, weil
das erste, was die Leute fragen ist,
wie sieht es mit Home Office und Remote Work aus?
Und er hat dann gesagt, ja,
er antwortet da immer ehrlich drauf so
und er hat da immer drauf geantwortet,
ja, während Corona ist das ziemlich gut, aber
danach ist es noch offen und
wahrscheinlich
maximal einen Tag die Woche
und dann hat er nie was von den Leuten wieder gehört.
Das muss reihenweise vorgekommen
sein.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn er nicht
ehrlich gewesen wäre, hätte er auch nichts gebracht,
dann wären die Leute halt einen Schritt später abgesprungen.
Also,
das ist halt auch Kacke für die
jeweilige Führungskraft, wenn sein Chef
wiederum so komische Entscheidungen trifft.
Nun gut, also Gehalt finde ich geht durchaus
in Ordnung, wobei ich keine Ahnung habe,
was man sonst so als Senior
SAP-Administrator verdienen kann.
Leider schon, weil es SAP ist, verdienst du damit wahrscheinlich
mehr als sonst.
Oben im Anhang befindet sich ein Exposé weiterer Details.
Ich freue mich auf unser Telefonat.
Ah, gut.
Sieht für mich nach einer ganz normalen
Anfrage aus,
die dort tausendfach
verschickt wird.
Die Antwort habe ich gelesen, da steht
einfach nur drauf,
in seiner Antwort steht drinnen,
wie der überhaupt auf die Idee kommt,
dass er SAP-Administrator werden will,
weil nirgendswo in seinem Lebenslauf,
ich kann es ja wohl zeigen,
nirgendswo in seinem Lebenslauf steht was von SAP.
Er fragt sich auch,
ob das wirklich sein kann,
dass sie konkret beauftragt wurden,
diese fünf Personen anzusprechen.
Ja, das ist, wie gesagt, im Leben nicht.
Aber ansonsten sieht es nach einer ganz normalen
Anfrage aus.
Das ist ja auch im Homeoffice möglich.
Jede schreiben die rein, dass die Leute nicht gleich abspringen.
Wichtig ist, was sie genau konkret
für Vereinbarungen haben.
Und wenn dann kommt so nach dem Motto,
ja, das muss man dann mit dem jeweiligen
Vorgesetzten und hier und da
und da ist das so und dann,
umso mehr sie sich darum drücken, weißt du,
es wird nicht viel gehen.
Das stimmt wohl?
Dass da der Auftraggeber drin steht,
ist ja schon mal was.
Die finden so wenig, dass sie auch Leute ohne SAP-Skills
einstellen. Hey,
ich habe mich gerade Fragen zum Quereinstieg.
Also, let's go, Leute.
SAP-Administrator.
Erzähl mal.
Wärst du jetzt System-Admin
bzw. Turnschuh-Admin, Max?
Ich wäre gerne Turnschuh-Admin
wieder. Also nicht
gehaltstechnisch, wie damals,
wobei das damals einstiegsmäßig echt gut
klar ging, finde ich.
Ich wäre gerne Turnschuh-Admin.
Ich würde gerne öfters ins Rechenzentrum.
Ich bin jetzt,
ich bin jetzt seit,
fast einem Jahr
bei der Versicherung in Frankfurt
und ich war noch nicht einmal im Rechenzentrum.
Hast du schon
mit SAP gearbeitet?
Also als Admin nicht, ne.
Wir haben einige Systeme, die auf SAP-Gedöns basieren,
aber mit SAP selbst habe ich nichts
großartiges zu tun.
Ich weiß nur, dass alle immer Anfälle bekommen,
wenn man SAP-HANA-Datenbank hört.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was da dahinter
steckt, aber
da hat keiner Bock drauf und es muss
alles fuck sein und outdated as fuck,
je nachdem, welche Version man hat.
Ja, ich schaue mir da ins
Slayern. Also ich wäre gerne wieder
Turnschuh-Admin und würde öfters ins Rechenzentrum.
In welche
Richtung würdest du dich aktuell spezialisieren?
Also pauschal
kann man das immer enorm schwer sagen,
weil es kommt halt darauf an, was dich persönlich
interessiert. Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Es macht wenig, also macht aus meiner Sicht
wenig Sinn, sich nur auf
irgendwas zu spezialisieren, weil man erhofft,
darauf irgendwie mehr Kapital schlagen
zu können. Da wird man nämlich
nicht richtig gut drin. Richtig gut wirst du
nie in Sachen oder sagen wir mal
größtenteils nur in Sachen,
die dich persönlich interessieren und
dementsprechend persönliche Motivation besteht,
sich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
Also ich persönlich würde
mich wahrscheinlich in genau die gleiche
Richtung entwickeln, wie ich jetzt
auch im neuen Job mache.
Deswegen hat ja auch die Stellenanzeige so gut
gepasst. Ich würde mich wahrscheinlich
weiter um Automatisierung,
also Server Automatisierung,
Infrastructure as Code, Cloud
Infrastruktur
und allgemeine DevOps
Geschichten kümmern.
Irgendwelche GitLab,
GitHub,
was gibt's denn da noch?
Pipelines
oder mit
was ist denn da gerade
voll angesagt, was so Systeme
angeht? Also
viele haben intern GitLab, offizielles GitHub,
aber was ist denn, also früher war Jenkins,
halt das Ding. Aber Jenkins hat
ja heute eigentlich kaum noch einer.
Also ich kenne viele, die benutzen GitHub
Actions und ich kenne viele, die
benutzen GitLab intern.
Aber was ist denn da sonst
noch so angesagt? Azure DevOps?
Wobei Azure DevOps,
Azure DevOps habe ich auch schon mal
benutzt beim alten Laden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie
groß die Zukunft da ist.
Was sind denn noch so für beliebte,
Moment, wo ist die Musik
hin? Was sind denn noch für
beliebte Bild,
beziehungsweise...
Nein.
Keine Weeb-Musik jetzt, Leute.
Keine Weeb-Musik. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich sie noch offen hab.
So Drone gab's früher noch
und sowas. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Also was mir aktuell so einfällt, ist tatsächlich
nur GitLab CI,
GitHub Actions,
ja, Jenkins,
immer noch
und fürs Ausrollen
sowas wie Argo CD oder Flux
in Kubernetes, aber das ist eine andere Anwendung.
Also ich würde mich genau in die
gleiche Richtung spezialisieren, wie ich's
gemacht hab, weil das ist, was mir gefällt.
Automatisierung,
Cloud-Infrastruktur,
Infrastructure as Code und generell
alles, was so ein bisschen
über den Tellerrand rausgeht,
von klassischer Administration hin zu
Anwendungsentwicklung.
Weil ich das nice finde,
sowohl mit der Infrastruktur
als auch mit Entwicklern zusammen was zu machen.
Ja, mit einem unserer Architekten bei uns
Software-Architekten verstehe ich mich eigentlich ganz gut
und wir gucken uns auch öfter
Sachen an und ich finde, da kommt auch immer was Sinnvolles raus,
wenn wir uns da Sachen zusammen angucken.
Also, das macht mir Spaß.
Ich entwickle die ein oder
anderen internen Tools für uns,
dass die Arbeit ein bisschen erleichtert.
Zum Beispiel das Ein- und
Ausbuchen
aus dem
Berufsbereitschaftssystem
hab ich auch ein Tool für gebaut.
Und ich beschäftige mich halt auch sehr gerne mit
Cloud-Infrastruktur
und Kubernetes im Speziellen.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich genau das
gleiche wieder machen.
Was hältst du von OpenStack-Abstand?
Niko hat schon was mitgemacht.
Ja, mach ich jetzt, mach ich jetzt.
Doch, viele Unternehmen
haben, also gerade in Frankfurt,
wo du hinspuckst, ist ein Rechenzentrum.
Doch, doch, viele Unternehmen haben noch eigene Rechenzentren.
Größere.
Ja, also,
keine Ahnung, die Schreinerei Müller
um die Ecke.
Wobei doch, die haben auch ein eigenes Rechenzentrum.
Das ist dann quasi der PC bei der Sekretärin
oder so. Aber
die nicht. Aber die haben wahrscheinlich
auch nix in der Cloud laufen.
Aber ich
geb dir schon recht,
es
ist insgesamt heutzutage
einfacher,
so Sachen auszulagern als ein eigenes
Rechenzentrum zu bauen, beziehungsweise
sich einzumieten,
wenn man nicht so groß ist.
Und vielleicht auch die bessere Entscheidung. Aber es gibt
trotzdem genug Unternehmen, die ein eigenes Rechenzentrum
haben.
Mit eigenem Rechenzentrum ist übrigens
nicht gemeint, dass das komplette Gebäude
dem jeweiligen
Unternehmen gehört.
Weil das ist tatsächlich noch
seltener der Fall.
Also die meisten, das schreibt ja auch
gerade hier der Flötenheinz,
also die meisten
Sachen sind
bei irgendeinem Anbieter,
Kleierstraße
in Frankfurt, Hanauer Landstraße,
sonst wo.
Da gibt's dann
mehrstöckige, ältere,
sind meistens ein bisschen ältere Gebäude,
die dann eins, zwei,
drei Stöcke halt ausgebaut
wurden zum Rechenzentrum. Da kannst du dir dann so
ein Abteil drin mieten.
Oder halt manchmal auch nur einzelne
Racks oder einzelne Stellplätze, aber
größere Unternehmen mieten sich dann quasi so einen
eigenen Serverraum im Endeffekt.
Stehen dann Racks drin, ist halt auch schon
alles da, von
Bau
bis Klimaanlage, doppelte Böden
und so, da musst du halt nix mehr selbst machen.
Und...
Ich hab's mal erlebt, dass beim Transport
in so eines dieser
gemieteten Rechenzentren,
da war der Fahrstuhl ein bisschen zu klein.
Aber der Transportdienst hat gemeint,
unser Storage passt trotzdem in den Fahrstuhl.
Und...
Es...
Ich kann euch sagen, bei einem Storage,
was wahrscheinlich locker
über drei, vier Millionen kostet, das war
ein komplettes Rack voll mit SSDs
und Business Enterprise Zeug
von IBM, was wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung,
drei, vier Millionen oder so kostet, so ein Storage.
Wenn ihr hört,
dass
Plastik zerbricht,
wenn der Liefer-, also
wenn der Transportdienst das Ding
aus dem Fahrstuhl fährt,
da habt ihr kein so gutes Gefühl dabei.
Die haben das Ding aus dem Fahrstuhl
gefahren, das hat dann wirklich, das hat schon
beim Reinschieben quasi
gekratzt an der Decke.
Und beim Rausschieben aus dem Fahrstuhl
hab ich nur noch Splittern gehört vom Plastik.
Am Ende
war das Ding auch oben ein bisschen kaputt,
aber wohl,
sagen wir mal, wohl nichts weltbewegendes.
Da waren oben so...
Ja,
weiß ich nicht, was ist denn, so Platten drauf,
wahrscheinlich für
besseren Airflow oder so
was. Und die sind halt abgesplittert,
als sie das aus dem Fahrstuhl geschoben
haben. Wahrscheinlich waren
die halbwegs leichtgängig in eine Richtung
und in die andere Richtung nicht.
Und dann hat's gesplittert. Zumindest
war das kein so gutes Gefühl, als ich gehört hab
beim Storage rausfahren oben
Ich mach tatsächlich
auch viel mit Blockchain auf der Arbeit.
Und hier, Luko,
ich guck's mir gleich an. Wir haben ja noch
eine Stunde Zeit.
Wo fängt man bei Serverautomatisierung am besten
an? Ansible. Ja, Ansible
ist ein guter Einstiegspunkt. Wenn es um
klassisches Server geht,
mit einem Linux drauf. Ich meine, Ansible kann
theoretisch auch Windows. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das wirklich
sich geben will.
Ich hab damals viel mit Puppet gemacht, als das
der neue heiße Scheiß war. Das konnte ja theoretisch auch
Windows, war aber Schrott as fuck.
Ja, aber Ansible ist ein guter Einstiegspunkt.
Sofern es um klassische Serversysteme
geht, die halt auch
ein bisschen mehr Konfiguration
brauchen, sei es
Einbindung für die Anmeldung
in den LDAP Server,
du brauchst spezielle IP-Configs,
du willst deine Festplatten in der Richtung
an den richtigen
Mountpoints haben. Also wenn du einen Server hast,
die Anwendung muss vielleicht initial mal
drauf, keine Ahnung. Also Pakete müssen
installiert werden, wenn du
SSH-Keys und alles mögliche.
Wenn du quasi Server hast,
die länger leben
und
gewissen Konfigurationsaufwand haben,
damit sie eben
von der einfachen installierten Linux-Kiste
zum eigentlichen Server dann werden,
der sie werden sollen, dann ist Ansible
eine super Geschichte.
Ich muss aber sagen, gerade im Cloud-Umfeld
der Trend geht eher dahin,
also ganz aussterben wird das nie.
Man wird immer
noch
VMs oder halt Server
brauchen mit einem Linux drauf, wo halt dann
auch ein bisschen mehr konfiguriert werden muss.
Sei es als irgendwelche
Jump-Hosts, Monitoring-Server,
was auch immer. Es wird immer welche geben,
die man braucht.
Aber der Trend geht ja davon weg
und das auch schon die letzten Jahre.
Gerade im Cloud-Umfeld geht der Trend
eher dahin, dass Systeme
einfach
auszutauschen sind.
Beziehungsweise einfach zu löschen
und wieder neu zu erzeugen sind.
Das kann man mit Ansible
unterstützen,
aber umso
weniger an einem einzelnen
System quasi zusätzlich
konfiguriert werden muss,
umso besser.
Container im Kubernetes-Cluster treiben
das Ganze auf die Spitze.
Da muss gar nichts mehr, außer die Anwendung
für den Container
konfiguriert werden.
Kannst du auch gar nicht.
Du kannst dein Container-Image booten
oder booten ist das falsche Wort, starten.
Du kannst die Anwendung in deinem Container-Image
starten. Das ist auch falsch ausgedrückt.
Du kannst nur noch die Anwendung starten,
die sich in deinem Container-Image
befindet, mit allen Abhängigkeiten
aus dem Container-Image.
Aber du verwendest weiterhin den Host-Körnel.
Und kannst
bis auf so ein paar Sachen wie
Mount-Points,
Environment-Variable und so gar nichts mehr ändern.
Aber der Trend geht da
generell hin. Also, dass die ganze
Infrastruktur möglichst
self-contained
ist, wenn es geht.
Und möglichst einfach
gelöscht und neu
erzeugt werden kann, ohne dass es
lange oder noch schlimmer
lange und manuelle Konfigurationsarbeiten
gibt. Ganz drum herum
kommen wird man nie.
Das heißt, Ansible ist eine super
Sache zu kennen.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal die
Stellanzeige von ihm an. Nicht das da. Das da.
Ich muss mal rüberschieben.
Wo habe ich es denn?
Ist das die Richtige?
Luko, ist das die Richtige hier?
Ja.
Oh, mein Auge.
Ich persönlich habe
ein weiches Herz für Jenkins.
Ich habe schon öfters gesagt, ich bin
in der Richtung nicht normal. Ich mag auch
Nagios. Ich würde keinen
neuen Nagios mehr aufsetzen.
Hätte ich mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt,
wenn jemand zu mir kommen würde
und sagt, Max, installiere uns mal
einen Nagios.
Ich hätte da wahrscheinlich sogar mal wieder Bock drauf.
Ich habe
ein Herz für Nagios und Jenkins.
Was spricht denn gegen Nagios?
Kappa.
Wenn du mich fragst, gar nichts.
Nagios ist
perfectly fine monitoring.
Das einzige, was
mich bei Nagios enorm abschreckt, ist
das für mich undurchsichtige
kann man es Lizenzmodell
nennen,
dass es irgendwie keinen normalen
Nagios mehr gibt, nur noch Enterprise und ich
keine Ahnung habe, welche Teile jetzt wie, wo drin sind.
Das war früher deutlich einfacher.
Ich würde, InfluxDB
ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so beliebt.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich ganz klassisch Prometheus
machen, wobei man sagen muss,
Prometheus
ist kein Ersatz für
Nagios oder Zabbix
oder
gibt es da noch
Checkmk und solche Sachen.
War das früher nicht Pearl?
Weiß gar nicht.
Nagios war schon immer C, glaube ich.
Ichinga und so.
PRTG für die Windows Enjoyers.
Da ist
Prometheus ja kein wirklicher Ersatz für.
Man kann
alles damit auch irgendwie
abbilden, aber man merkt schon, dass es
nicht primär dafür gedacht
ist. Prometheus ist
super zum Metriken einsammeln
und gerade wenn du viele Datenpunkte
hast, beispielsweise
sowas wie Garbage Collector Runs
oder irgendwelche
Anwendungsprofile, irgendwas, wo du
viel einsammelst, viele
Metriken hast und
auch jetzt nicht einfaches
is up, is down haben möchtest
oder is über 80%
Festplatte, is unter 80%
Festplatte oder sowas, da ist Prometheus
cool. Irgendwelche internen
Anwendungsmetriken so, äh,
wie ist die Auslastung vom Threadpool?
Wie verteilt
sich das? Dafür ist Prometheus
richtig nice, gerade wenn die jeweilige
Anwendung Prometheus Sachen zur Verfügung
stellt. Und dann visualisieren
mit Grafana auch wunderbar.
Für so klassische Dinger wie
ich will wissen, ob
der SSH-Port noch offen ist
auf irgendeinem Endpunkt
und dann ein Alert
schicken,
finde ich klassische Monitoring-Tools
wie Zabbix immer noch angenehmer.
Man kann das mit Prometheus machen,
aber Prometheus in der Beziehung
ist eher ein ich bastel mir ein Monitoring
selber, weil da ist nix
fertig von. Also was du beispielsweise
bei Zabbix, okay, Zabbix
ist ein doofes Beispiel, weil Zabbix ist auch
unnötig kompliziert, aber
is zum größten noch so ne klassische
Monitoring-Lösung. Bei Zabbix kriegst du das
alles out of the box, ja.
Bei Prometheus musst du das selbst
bauen. Du musst dich erstmal selbst
um das Einsammeln kümmern,
dann musst du dich wie Banagher, wie
bei Zabbix natürlich drüber, dass du
überall deine Node-Exporter installiert hast,
dann musst du noch irgendwelche
Blackbox-Checks machen, wenn du die klassischen
Monitoring-Dinge abbilden willst,
dann musst du dir Gedanken drüber machen, wie machst du
die Visualisierung, dann musst du dir Gedanken drüber machen,
wie machst du das Alerting,
da brauchst du sowas wie Alert-Manager,
wie richtest du da die Rules am besten
ein, welche Notification-
Channels brauchst du, alles.
Also, wenn du klassisches
Monitoring, also wenn du nicht nur Metric machen
willst, sondern wirklich komplettes Monitoring
abfackeln möchtest mit Prometheus,
dann ist das ein, ich baue mir mein Monitoring
selbst.
Ja, da kommt noch sowas wie Loki dabei,
Promtail und alle möglichen Dinge,
du baust dir dein Monitoring selbst im Endeffekt
damit.
Hat auch seine Vorteile.
Aber wenn du einfach nur
simples SSH-Port ist offen
oder zu haben willst, dann ist sowas
wie Nagios okay,
da ist sowas wie Zabbix okay,
da kannst du Checkmk verwenden, ist das
okay für...
Man kann immer ein Fan von die Tools dafür
zu verwenden, wo sie ihre Stärken haben.
Ja, man kann mit Grafana, Grafana hat ja
auch noch Alerting-Möglichkeiten seit ein paar Versionen,
kann alles irgendwie immer
irgendwie mit dem anderen Tool auch
hindrehen, aber
unterschiedliche Software hat da seine
unterschiedlichen Stärken. So, jetzt gucken wir uns
das aber an. Ups.
Checkmk check ich die Swap-Interface nicht,
ich find da nix. Also, was
haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
ICT-System-Engineer für Cloud
und IT-Services. MWD,
80 bis 100 Prozent, oh!
80!
Also, das ist in der Schweiz, okay.
Ich wollt grad sagen, wollen die mich abwärmen?
Weil bei mir ist 80 Prozent Pflicht.
Ich werd nie wieder 100 Prozent arbeiten,
das sag ich euch.
Sei das passiert, was super
unvorhergesehen ist, man weiß ja nie, ja.
Aber ich habe nicht
vor jemals wieder 100 Prozent zu arbeiten.
Was sind eure Lieblings-Linux-Distros?
8 Spideway.
Einzig Ware.
Auf Desktop, auf
Desktop. Debian auf dem Server.
Also, lasst uns
das mal kurz angucken.
Die Slinet
AG
ist ein dynamisches und erfolgreiches
Schweizer IT-Unternehmen in dem Bereich
Cloud und IT-Services.
Okay.
Die übliche Sache, aber glücklicherweise
ist die Selbstbeweihräucherung kurz und
knackig.
Business Cloud und IT-Services am Standort
Lupfig
oder Loopfig?
Nee, wahrscheinlich Lupfig.
Ist Fucking
nicht auch irgendwo in der Schweiz gewesen
oder in Österreich?
Wo war Fucking?
Der Ort, der Fucking heißt.
Österreich, ja.
Sucht ein Engagiertes und Motiviertes.
Was ich gut finde an der Stellenanzeige
ist,
die Selbstbeweihräucherung ist
on point und
kurz und knackig.
Nicht googeln.
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Okay, als ICT
Internet
und Cloud?
Was heißt denn ICT eigentlich?
Oder Infrastructure
and Cloud Technologies?
Oder
wäre es nicht cool reinzuschreiben?
Oder vielleicht bin ich einfach zu Pipega, das zu sehen.
Telefon
heißt das.
Ist das eine gängige Schweizer Abkürzung?
Ich hab das noch nie gehört.
Ja,
okay.
Als ICT
System Engineer
identifizieren Sie Anforderungen auf der Basis
von Kundenbedürfnissen und entwickeln Lösungen
dazu.
Das ist super
allgemein.
Sie konzipieren ganz eigentliche Systemlösungen,
kleinen Netzwerkserver,
übernehmen Projektleads.
Nee.
Sie suchen keinen Projektmanager, sie suchen einen
System Engineer für Cloud IT Services.
Kein Projektmanager.
Und arbeiten
selbstständig mit an dessen Techno-
Organisation.
Unser Team und unsere Kunden
unterstützen Sie bei der Aufgabe
als Störungsfällen.
Sie organisieren sich selbst
und sind zuständig
für die Qualifizierung und Priorisierung
von entgegengenommen Aufträgen, Störungen
und Supportfällen.
Diese bearbeiten Sie im Rahmen
der Betriebsverantwortung.
Die Kenntnisse weitgehen selbstständig,
weil wir darauf halten, Sie unterstützen.
Nach ihrer umfassenden
Einarbeit erhalten Sie die Möglichkeit,
schrittweise die Betriebsverantwortung
einzeln zu übernehmen.
Technische Ansprechpersonen, Wartung,
Weiterentwicklungs-Service.
Klingt ja ziemlich klassisch
eigentlich.
Klingt fast schon nach einem ganz normalen
Admin, irgendwie,
der da gesucht wird.
3 Jahre bla bla
Erfahrung abgeschlossene
Stu-
Was ist Informatiker
EVZ?
EFZ?
Eingeständige Lösungsfindung durch analytische Struktur,
Arbeitsweise, hohe Lernbereitschaft,
Ach, Ausbildung, okay.
Was hältst du hiervon?
Wollte jetzt eigentlich heute gar nicht so viel gucken,
aber ich mache es gleich auf,
erinnere mich gleich nochmal dran.
Fundierte Kenntnisse in den Bereichen Microsoft
365 und Office 365.
Immerhin, Leute, immerhin,
Pleading Edge,
sie nennen es Microsoft 365
und nicht mehr Office 365.
Das haben die bestimmt nur reingeschrieben,
weil der Luko mal in den Stream geguckt hat.
Windows Server und
Client, Active Directory,
Virtualisierungslösung, Hyper-V,
Mon-KS,
sowie IP-Systeme,
Freude am direkten Kundenkontakt.
.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der da Freude dran hat?
Sie sind ein Macher
und schließen Arbeiten
vollständig ab.
High-Performer-Crimeset-Mindset.
Was für ein Ding?
Okay, das ist irgendein Schweizer Ding,
wo ich keine Ahnung habe, was es bedeuten soll.
Heißt das sowas wie Rufbereitschaft?
Ist das Rufbereitschaft auf Schweizerisch?
Ja, okay, gut.
Habe ich richtig geraten?
Steelsicheres Deutsch
sowie Verständigung in Englisch.
Benefits.
Vielseitiger Aufgabenbereich,
abflexungsreicher Kunden,
Stammaufgaben von Engineering,
okay, bla bla.
Agiles und nachhaltiges,
nee, agiles und nachhaltig
inhabergeführtes Unternehmen.
.
Hybrid ist Arbeit möglich, okay.
Ist das auch so, Luko?
Also, wie hoch ist der Homeoffice-Anteil?
.
Weil das schreiben ja viele.
Arbeitszeiten innerhalb
zwei Tage die Woche.
.
Also, also ich,
also ich finde, ein Tag Anwesenheit
die Woche reicht.
Arbeitszeiten innerhalb, okay, also,
es würde auch noch weniger reichen, ja.
Arbeitszeiten innerhalb eines vorgegebenen
Rahmens, Selbsteinplan, eigenes personalisierba-
ein eigenes personalisierbares Büro.
Okay, das ist cool.
Ein eigenes Büro.
Da hat man seine Ruhe.
Vielleicht ist es auch ein Großraumbüro,
du kriegst einen eigenen Tisch.
50-Polt-Kostenbeteiligung am Parkplatz,
Budget für eigene Hardware, Ausfallhaushalte.
Naja.
Ich meine, dass die mir Arbeitsgeräte zur Verfügung
stellen, würde ich schon erwarten.
Aktuell fokussieren wir uns aktiv auf die Transformation
unserer Kunden zu gemanagten, hybriden
Cloud-Lösungen. Oh.
Chatge, falls sich da irgendjemand bewirbt,
da müsst ihr unbedingt das Wort
Hyperscaler droppen.
Im Bewerbungsgespräch.
Das geht ab, da freuen die sich.
Hyperscaler.
Kontinuierliches Feedback dank
OKR, alles klar.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wofür das genau
steht, aber das ist wahrscheinlich Key
Key Results und
keine Ahnung.
Hyperscaler, ja, Hyperscaler.
Man nennt das heute nicht mehr
Cloud-Anbieter. Man nennt das
Hyperscaler. Nicht Hypervisor-
Scaler. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Hyperscaler.
Nennt man das.
Cloud-Anbieter, cool Leute
nennen heutzutage Cloud-Anbieter
und nicht mehr irgendwie Cloud-Anbieter
Cloud-Provider. Nein, man nennt die
heutzutage Hyperscaler.
Was kommt eigentlich nach Hyperscaler,
Ultrascaler? Also meine Vermutung ist,
danach kommt irgendwie eine andere
Wortkombination. Ja.
Die
Stellenanzeige ist sehr
0815, finde ich.
Ist jetzt nichts, wo man wegrennt,
ist jetzt aber auch nichts, wo man sagen würde,
oh ja,
nie dagewesen, da muss ich unbedingt hin.
Oder Chat, wie seht ihr das?
Max, das ist mein Nachfolger,
da habe ich gekündigt und gehe jetzt in eine
Softwarebude, GLHF.
Dann, wenn du da
gekündigt hast, dann ist mal die
Frage an dich.
Wie findest du denn die Stellenanzeige,
beziehungsweise würdest du dich darauf bewerben nochmal?
Also, ne.
Und wenn du es nicht wüsstest.
Was verdient ihr so netto? Ich bin,
das, da kommen wir gleich zu.
Komm, gleich mal was
Umfragen stellen.
Jetzt gucke ich mir noch das andere an,
weil das komme ich heute überhaupt nicht hinterher.
Das haben wir vom Chainlore, Fachinformatiker,
Deutsche Bank.
Oder wie die Amis immer sagen,
Da ist
jetzt der Chainlore, so so.
Ja, viel Erfolg bei deiner Ausbildung,
Chainlore.
Ich hoffe, du wirst nicht gleich gebannt.
Du wirst mal BuberTV aufmachen am ersten Tag.
Das solltest
du mitbringen.
Ausdauer und Zuverlässigkeit.
Gut, dass sie den Streamchat
hier nicht sehen.
Ah ja. Aber seriously, ich glaube,
die Ausbildung gerade so im Frankfurter
Finanzsektor ist nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, da hast du nichts verkehrt gemacht mit.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir das gleiche
aufgemacht.
Und dann hatten wir noch was.
Das ist Github, das ist ein Klon von
Github Actions.
GTA Actions.
Leute, könnt ihr ein NAS empfehlen?
Nein.
Ich habe kein fertiges NAS.
Ist der Punchchamp tatsächlich im Einsatz?
Ja, der Punchchamp ist nicht nur bei
mir im Einsatz, der Punchchamp ist sogar
schon bei jemand in einem anderen Team
im Einsatz.
Na, es läuft.
Ich würde gerne mal wieder in Dezix rein,
was ich da so getan habe die letzten Jahre.
Ich war lange nicht mehr drin.
Man wird bestimmt immer noch gewogen,
was ich tun will.
Hey,
dazu muss ich was sagen.
Früher, Moment,
Maps, Frankfurt,
ja, äh,
Beruf und
Familie Service.
What?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich würde eher, ähm,
Frankfurt
Kleierstraße
90 glaube ich.
90?
Da haben wir, früher hatten wir dort
ein, ähm,
früher hatten wir dort ein Rechenzentrum
gemietet, also einen Raum
gemietet.
Und dort, ach, wie sieht denn Maps
so kacke aus, Mann.
Not now.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich heute wieder in Main wohne.
Ja, ich wohne wieder in Main.
Frankfurt Kleierstraße
90 Frankfurt.
Genau, wir hatten früher ein Rechenzentrum
gemietet und dort war
am Empfang
die wahrscheinlich
unfreundlichste
Empfangsdame
aller Zeiten.
Ähm, wir waren,
boah, wo waren wir?
Das sieht von oben so anders aus.
Das ist da, wo ich mit Felix
zusammen auch mal, äh,
IBM Plates durch die
Straßenbahn in Frankfurt getragen habe.
Und dann hat's geregnet und wir hatten so die,
die, die Plates unter, unter der Jacke
und die haben uns alle angeguckt, als würden wir da irgendwie
Waffen transportieren oder so.
Street, Streetview,
ja.
Ich weiß nicht, hier vorne ist doch ein McDonalds.
Wo ist der McDonalds? Gibt's den überhaupt noch?
Mac?
Da war früher mal da immer ein McDonalds.
Irgendwo an der Ecke. Gibt's den nicht
mal? Nicht rumspammen,
Chainlord.
Ey, weil wenn ich weiß, wo
der McDonalds ist, wo ist,
okay, wo ist die Straßenbahn-Haltestelle?
Hier?
Ordnungsamt!
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Lebstockstraße,
Straße,
Schwalbachstraße?
Also keine Ahnung,
irgendwo war hier früher ein McDonalds,
dann wüsste, wüsste ich aus welcher Richtung wir gekommen sind.
Äh,
Equinix war hier unten auch,
ja, ja, da sind wir schon richtig.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung mehr.
Das ist da, wo die,
das ist übrigens auch dort, wo die, wo die
von unserem Storage das Dach abgebrochen haben.
Ähm,
vielleicht sieht das heute auch anders
aus. Ich, ich erkenne das von oben
nicht richtig.
Ich vermute, also, ich vermute
gegenüber,
das müsste hier sein, weil guck mal, hier sind auch die ganzen,
die ganzen, der ganze,
ist das Klimaanlagen-Stelz, den man hier sieht?
Auf dem Dach?
Moment, es gibt Street View hier drinnen?
Nee, oder?
Aber es gibt, es gibt Street View
hier neben.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, das kommt mir
bekannt vor, aber das
ist nicht der Eingang gewesen, wo ich immer
rein bin.
Das kommt mir aber bekannt vor.
Zumindest
gibt es dort einen Anbieter, der heißt
Itenos.
Ah, findet man ja. Ja, hier ist
doch das Bild. Genau, so sieht
die Einfahrt aus, genau so.
Ja.
Und, und wir, hier, das Rechensendover
hier auf der linken Seite.
So.
Und, ohne Scheiß, Itenos
hat die
unmotivierteste und nervigste
Empfangsdame aller Zeiten
gehabt. Und nicht nur
eine. Damen.
Was haben die denn
für Reviews?
Ja, deckt sich,
deckt sich auch mit meiner Erfahrung,
ja. Vielleicht sind die aber
auch besser.
Top, top IT-Dienstleister.
Ne, die waren alle in dieser, dieser, dieser
Uniform von dem Laden. Die haben dort schon
gearbeitet. Na gut, vielleicht war
es auch die Tochter vom Chef, genau.
Okay. Vielleicht
sind die viel besser geworden. Keine Ahnung.
Die waren super
unfreundlich.
Echt? Die gehören zur Telekom? Wirklich?
Damals aber
noch nicht. Das war
doch meine Turnschul-Admin-Zeiten, so.
Okay, what the fuck, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet?
Wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich drauf, drauf
gekommen? Ah ja, genau.
Ja, da hatten wir auch einige
Dinger.
Hyper-Scaler, da ist es doch, ja.
Ja, Nagios ist hässlich wie die Nacht.
Ich finde, Nagios hat ein ganz gutes Config-Format.
Kannst alles per Text konfigurieren,
nix geklicke wie bei Zabbix.
Find die
Server-Vererbung in Nagios auch ganz cool.
So dann quasi
anlegen kannst. Ich habe ein...
Base-Linux-Server, der soll das, das
und das bekommen.
Wie gesagt, Nagios ist, glaube ich, in C selbst
programmiert. Das ist so alt, das muss
in C sein.
MrSnAlive, dankeschön für den
Sub. Sorry, falls ich irgendjemand
vergessen habe. Ich gucke gerade mal.
MrAmec, POG-Subscription nicht gesehen.
Crisat,
auch am Start. POG, dankeschön, Leute.
Da ist er.
Ja, war es auch. Ich habe in meiner
Ausbildung viel Nagios gemacht. Das sollte
alles über den Alter dieser Software sagen.
Ich mag JackMK,
das Web-Interface nicht.
Kennt wer ein relativ
günstiges Monitoring, was viel mitbringt,
einfach zu konfigurieren? Es ist ganz
davon abhängig, was du brauchst.
Brauchst du
Metriken in Form von
Festplattenauslastung?
Oder brauchst du nur einfaches
Up-Down-Monitoring? Also brauchst
du sowas wie, ich möchte gerne wissen,
wie sich die letzten 14 Tage
die RAM-Auslastung auf diesem System
verhalten hat? Oder reicht es dir,
wenn du weißt, Service ist Up oder Down?
Weil wenn es dir reicht,
zu sagen, Port ist auf,
HTTP-Response ist okay,
Ping ist okay, dann gibt es
richtig gute Sachen, super simpel.
Wenn du allerdings
so ein bisschen Langzeitdaten
haben möchtest zu RAM-Auslastung,
Festplattenauslastung, eingeloggte User
und sowas, dann brauchst du schon ein bisschen
was umfangreicheres. Ja, zum Beispiel
was wie Zabbix oder JackMK.
Wobei du da auch halt
sagen kannst, ey, die einfachen
Up-Down-Monitoring-Sachen,
die mache ich mit sowas wie UptimeKuma,
wobei das sicherlich nicht auf
Enterprise-Größe gut
skaliert, ja, im Heimbereich, sagen wir mal.
Also ich glaube, dass
UptimeKuma schon seine Probleme hat mit 4000
Systemen. Nie ausprobiert,
aber ich gehe ganz stark davon aus.
Das ist irgendeine Single-Threaded
ExpressJS-Backend,
was da die Checks ausführt, das hat
bestimmt seine Probleme.
Und dann zusätzlich
die Metriken mit Prometheus zu sammeln.
Ansonsten ist Zabbix
eine gute All-in-One-Lösung.
Das große Problem bei Zabbix
ist die
undurchsichtigste
Konfiguration ever
übers Web-Interface.
Du musst grad mal gucken, Zabbix
Roadmap, ich hab da immer noch
einen Blick drauf, grad mal gucken,
was da, was da, ok, ja, guck mal,
7.0 LTS, hab ein paar Sachen schon
verpasst. JackMK,
ich
komme mit dem Web-Interface von
JackMK einfach nicht klar.
Das wirkt auf der einen Seite
modern und auf der anderen Seite ultra
altbacken und ich finde nix.
Ich meine,
bei Zabbix,
wenn man sich dran gewöhnt,
wo was steht, findet man's
eigentlich, dafür ist die Einstiegshürde
bei Zabbix enorm hoch.
Aber bei JackMK, ich kann mir dort
einfach ums Verrecken nicht merken, wo was ist.
Das hab ich auch gesehen,
das fand ich ganz interessant,
weil da kannst du quasi in
einer Oberfläche
so klassisches Up-Down-Monitoring
machen plus Prometheus-Daten,
aber die haben so ein ganz merkwürdiges
Lizenzmodell, das hab ich mir nie weiter
angeguckt.
Linux Distro, Arch Linux.
Achso,
ok, du bist ein, wenn du Einsteiger bist,
nimm Linux Mint, da kannst du eigentlich nicht viel falsch machen.
Den Nagios Plugins
konnten schon immer.
Achso, ich weiß nicht, was du für Plugins meinst,
also Nagios Checks konnten schon
immer in jeder beliebigen
Programmiersprache entwickelt werden.
Ja, seh ich
genauso. Teilzeitarbeiten
beste. Und gerade wenn wir
in der IT hier, wenn viele hier weiß,
wir arbeiten in der IT, wir verdienen ja eh ganz gut
unterm Strich,
die meisten können sich das leisten,
einen Tag weniger zu arbeiten. Und es ist
einfach so viel angenehmer.
Es klingt jetzt trivial, was ich
sage, aber ihr müsst euch immer
vergegenwärtigen, vier Tage Woche
bedeutet nicht nur einen Tag mehr
Wochenende.
Oder einen Tag mehr frei.
Es bedeutet auch gleichermaßen
einen Tag weniger arbeiten.
Klingt naheliegend, denken aber
viele nicht dran.
Es ist ja, also
zumindest habe ich den Eindruck,
viele sehen eine
80% Stelle
eher so im Kopf, so nach dem
Motto, ja cool, dann habe ich
einen Tag mehr Arbeit,
aber die denken dann weiterhin so nach dem Motto,
aber dann wieder fünf Tage arbeiten. Das ist ja
Blödsinn. Natürlich
ist auch jedem klar, wenn er, aber es ist
realisieren viele nicht,
dass es eben zwei Vorteile
hat. Ein Tag mehr frei
und ein Tag weniger arbeiten,
was dafür sorgt, dass du noch
mehr Zeit hast.
Weil du nicht so müde bist
und nicht so kaputt bist.
Und du auch nicht dieses, ab Sonntag
Mittag habe ich keinen Bock mehr was zu machen, weil ich
morgen wieder arbeiten gehen muss, Phänomen
hast. Du hast,
dadurch, dass du nur vier Tage am Stück gearbeitet
hast, kannst du drei Tage
durchgängig
ohne
dieses, oh ich bin so kaputt, ich hänge im Prinzip
jetzt ja eh nur den ganzen Samstag in den Seilen
bis mittags,
kannst du einfach drei Tage dich komplett auf das
konzentrieren, was du machen willst oder was erledigt
werden muss, ohne
zu große Erschöpfungszustände
von der Woche.
Ein Tag mehr frei für dich
und ein Tag weniger arbeiten.
Weil überleg mal, der nächste
Schritt wäre,
noch ein Tag weniger arbeiten und noch
ein Tag weniger arbeiten bedeutet schon
vier Tage frei zu drei Tage
arbeiten. Also
ich finde 80%
vier Tage Woche ist das Beste.
Du hast drei Tage Zeit
am Stück, wenn man es richtig nimmt,
alles zu machen, wo du Bock drauf
hast und dann sind es nur noch vier Tage
bis zum nächsten drei Tagen.
Ich finde das optimal.
Das ist für mich der beste Kompromiss auch, es gibt immer noch
fett Kohle und
ist aber
viel entspannter und
angenehmer.
Welchen Tag hast du frei?
Ich habe montags frei.
Ich persönlich finde montags auch am besten.
Erstens, freitags passiert meistens eh nichts.
Zweitens,
montags sind die Leute
immer super krass motiviert.
Das hat sich Dienstag schon wieder gelegt.
Das heißt,
montags bist du am Start, passiert eh nicht viel,
kannst du schon ein bisschen chillen fürs
Wochenende.
Montag, wo die alle super motiviert sind
und alle Status wissen wollen und sonst wie, bist du
nicht da und am Dienstag geht es dann wieder.
Also ich arbeite Dienstag,
Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag
und Montag habe ich frei und dann
habe ich quasi dann
Samstag, Sonntag, Montag frei.
Die skalieren diagonal.
Das machen nur wir hier.
Chainlord, wenn du sowas öffentlich im Chat
postest, bist du bestimmt jetzt auf irgendeiner Liste.
Da würde ich aufpassen,
wenn es das nächste Mal klingelt.
Das ist ein Command-Line-Tool,
was ich entwickelt habe,
womit man sich
bei unserem
Rufbereitschaft-Service
an- und abmelden kann automatisch.
Dass man nicht nachts angerufen wird aus Versehen.
Ja, ich habe eine Android-Lizenz.
Ich habe auch immer noch Android im Einsatz.
Richtig hundertprozentig zufrieden bin ich
nix, aber war ich mit was anderem
bisher auch nicht im Heimbereich.
Wie würdest du BWL Strongs Leuten erklären,
dass es keine gute Idee ist,
eine DB direkt zu exposen?
Du kannst ihnen sagen,
der nächste Twitter Shitstorm
mit dem Namen der Firma drinnen,
wenn ihr das macht, dauert nicht lange.
Lässt nicht lange auf sich warten.
Was angeblich wäre eine REST-AP
nicht performant genug
Dann soll man sich mal eine ordentliche
Anwendungsarchitektur überlegen.
Zumal du hier sogar
schönes Caching implementieren kannst
und nicht jeden Furz jedes Mal
neu aus der Datenbank holen musst.
Du willst doch nicht irgendwelche
SQL-Querys übers Internet schicken.
Was wird mit den Leuten immer los?
Sag denen, es dauert nicht lange
dann steht die Firma im nächsten Shitstorm
weil irgendwelche Datenleaks
oder sowas sind
in der Presse.
Sag ihnen als Beispiel,
sie sollen sich den Fall
Modern Solution angucken.
Die haben auch ihre Datenbank
Frag ob sie so enden wollen
wie Modern Solution.
Wie wollen die denn überhaupt
das Login gescheit absichern?
Wollen die dann jedem, der die Software runterlädt
einen eigenen Account anlegen
und dem irgendwie ein Passwort schicken oder sowas?
Was er dann einträgt in irgendeine Config?
Das ist super weird, Alter.
Geht nur um
ein internes Tool.
Das kann man machen,
wenn es nicht anders geht.
Aber ich finde Datenbank
außerhalb, also generell
Datenbank irgendwie im Netzwerk exposen
ist immer Painschamp.
Da spricht,
da ist immer irgendwas nicht richtig durchdacht.
Sobald die Datenbank
mit mehr kommunizieren muss
als mit dem Service
beziehungsweise den Services
bin ich das Painschamp.
Natürlich ist es okay,
wenn du ein API Backend hast,
das greift auf die Datenbank zu.
Du hast das vielleicht mehrfach skaliert,
das heißt es greifen mehrere Sachen auf die Datenbank zu.
Du hast vielleicht noch irgendwelche
Business und Background Jobs,
die Sachen arbeiten, die greifen darauf.
Das ist alles okay,
aber sobald von außerhalb
von dem jeweiligen Service Netz
oder von dem jeweiligen Service Konstrukt
darauf zugegriffen wird,
finde ich das immer,
das stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Mr. SNA live, danke für den Sub.
Das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Observium ist cool für Netzwerkhardware,
aber ich glaube
für generelles
Monitoring
auch für Solversysteme
ist das gar nicht so sehr gedacht.
Observium ist glaube ich ein Fork von irgendwas anderem,
was sich hauptsächlich auf
Monitoring über SNMP
und Netzwerkinfrastruktur
spezialisiert hat.
Das ist ziemlich sicher
uptime Kuma.
Für so ein paar Sachen
und so ein Portal ist das kein Ding.
Dafür ist das gut.
Ja das stimmt.
Wie gesagt, Linux Mint
Fedora, ich mag Fedora nicht.
Nimm Linux Mint, da kannst du nicht viel falsch machen.
Ist, finde ich, die beste
Einsteiger-Distribution.
Das ist die Status-Page von Atlassian.
Es sieht super krass nach uptime Kuma aus.
Hier auch mit den Balken.
Wir können ja mal gucken, was das ist.
Es ist...
Wir wissen es nicht.
Atlassian.
Okay, es ist Atlassian, es ist nicht uptime Kuma.
Es ist die Atlassian-Status-Page.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Deswegen.
Und du hast die zwei Vorteile,
die ich schon gesagt habe.
Du hast einen Tag länger frei
und du bist nicht so kaputt.
Du musst dich gar nicht groß erholen,
weil du einen Tag weniger gearbeitet hast.
Und mit Montag skippst du den stressigsten Tag.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber viele bekommen heute eh nicht genug Rente.
Also...
Da muss eh der ETF her.
Wer zahlt es, wenn weniger gearbeitet wird?
Ähm...
Dann...
Du kriegst einfach weniger Geld.
Ich bekomme nur 80%
des Gehalts von einer 100% Stelle.
Und in der Summe
macht es überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Wenn es...
Gut...
In der Theorie macht es überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Wenn es vier Leute gibt,
die Teilzeitarbeit in 80%
musst du halt noch einen fünften einstellen.
Unterm Strich kostet sich das genau das gleiche.
Ja, ich weiß,
natürlich in der Praxis ist es nicht so.
Du musst den erstmal finden.
Es gibt bestimmt auch ein paar
Informationsaustausch-Reibungsverluste.
Aber rein rechnerisch ist das so.
Und gerade die ganzen BWL Strongs
Leute rechnen ja gerne in PT.
Und in PT und Gehalt
und Geld macht es keinen Unterschied.
Äh...
Ob du vier oder fünf hast,
wenn du vier mit 80% hast?
Personentage, PT.
Unrate will ja jetzt jährlich Geld haben.
Haha, lul.
Können wir nicht machen.
Ich habe da eine Lizenz gekauft.
Lange.
Ich meine, wenn die dir
80% arbeiten lassen
und 100% Geld bezahlen wollen, ist auch nice.
Gibt ja so Versuche.
Ich glaube sogar die Deutsche Bank
oder die Commerzbank, die machen jetzt irgendwie
sowas, zumindest
das stand in irgendeinem Presseartikel.
Was die wirklich machen, weiß ich natürlich auch nicht.
Dass die jetzt anbieten wollen
vier Tage Woche.
Und vier Tage Woche bei denen bedeutet allerdings nicht
80% Zeit, sondern
es fällt quasi ein halber Tag
an Arbeitszeit weg.
Und den anderen halben Tag können die Leute
quasi an den vier Tagen zusätzlich arbeiten.
Also sie arbeiten dann quasi
anstatt siebeneinhalb oder so
achteinhalb Stunden an dem Tag
und dann können sie dafür Freitag daheim bleiben.
Also sie kriegen quasi einen halben Tag geschenkt
und einen halben Tag müssen sie
auf die anderen Tage verteilen.
Ja, Commerz, machen wir.
Ich bin gleich fertig mit dem Chat.
Ja genau, genau.
Ja, sollen sie mal machen.
Leute, ich werde alles unterstützen,
wo das irgendwie
gefördert
werden soll.
Deswegen finde ich es auch sehr gut, dass die Bahn
fordert vier Tage Woche.
Ich finde es mega kacke,
die streiken übrigens demnächst wieder.
Ich finde es mega kacke und bin ultra abgefuckt,
wenn die streiken.
Und ich bin da auch nicht, wie sie auf Twitter immer schreiben,
oh, da muss man solidarisch mit den Streikenden sein,
den Scheiß muss ich sein.
Ich muss pünktlich ankommen, der Rest ist mir egal.
Ich bin dafür,
dass vier Tage Woche möglichst normal
werden sollte.
Weil wisst ihr, was das bedeutet für jemand,
der jetzt schon vier Tage Woche arbeitet?
Wenn vier Tage Woche normal wird.
Habt ihr eine Idee, was das
bedeuten könnte?
Was könnte es bedeuten?
Pause-Champ.
Das kann zwei Sachen bedeuten.
Entweder
ich bekomme 20% mehr Geld
oder
ich arbeite noch einen Tag weniger.
Das bedeutet entweder drei Tage Woche
oder 20% mehr Geld.
Das heißt,
oder 15, je nachdem, wie sie es dann im Endeffekt machen.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
ich bin für alle Änderungen,
dass vier Tage Woche normal wird, zu haben.
Gäbe es eine
vier Tage Woche Partei,
dann wüsste ich wenigstens, wen ich wählen sollte.
Wen ich wählen soll.
Nee, haben wir doch schon öfters gemacht.
So, aber,
ich sollte noch mal daran erinnert werden,
dass ich mir,
wo ist es denn überhaupt?
Moment, hier habe ich es doch.
DM-Jobs? Nee.
Oder?
Ist das das, was du gepostet hast?
DM-Jobs?
Wo war denn der Schnitt vom High-IQ-Chat?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Äh.
Hallo?
Man, das eben nicht funktioniert.
Habe ich Cookies abgelehnt?
Wir, wir
schwätzen nur. Und da auch nur noch 20 Minuten.
Okay, also,
was haben wir denn hier?
Unified Communications.
So.
Unified Communications Administrator.
Am DM-Platz.
Moment, das heißt wirklich
am DM-Platz.
Die haben einen eigenen
Platz. Warum nicht?
Moderne und
zuverlässige Kommunikation.
Kommunikationssysteme bilden die Basis
für die digitale Unterstützung unserer Arbeit.
Blablabla.
Okay.
Die übliche Selbstbeweihräucherung.
Ah, ne. Da steht tatsächlich sogar was Sinnvolles drin.
Siehste? Das ist halt genau das Ding.
Man ist gewöhnt,
dass alle Stellenanzeigen
mit so einer sinnlosen Selbstbeweihräucherung
anfangen. Und wenn die genauso aussehen
und genauso anfangen, aber dann im zweiten Satz
sogar was halbwegs Interessantes kommt,
hast du schon wieder nicht gelesen.
Genauso wie die deine Bewerbung
von Weggeschmissen hätten, wenn dir irgendwas im ersten Satz
nicht gefällt. Also.
Moderne und zuverlässige Kommunikation.
Unser Team Unified Communications ist maßgeblich
an der Weiterentwicklung von Telekommunikationslösungen
wie Microsoft Teams beteiligt.
Was? Die entwickeln Teams
weiter? Ne.
Die werden irgendwelche Addons
und Workflows und so entwickeln
für Teams.
Darüber hinaus verantworten sie den Betrieb der
UC-Lösung.
Muss man wissen, was das ist?
Command and Conquer Generals.
Läuft das überhaupt noch auf aktuellen Rechnern?
Ach, Unified Communications.
Da hätte ich auch selbst drauf kommen können,
wenn ich den Titel gelesen habe.
Als Unified Communications Spezialist
bist du gemeinsam mit deinen Kollegen
aus dem Produktteam für
reibungslosen Betrieb und Weiterentwicklung
...
Okay, das gucken wir uns gleich noch an.
Was ein Administrator
eine Administratorin
bei DM-Tech macht.
...
Drei Frisuren für mittellanges Haar.
Geheime Haarpflegetipps.
Genau das.
Das wollte ich jetzt sehen.
Ja. Erstmal den Server einschmieren.
Mit irgendeiner Creme.
Es ist sehr trocken im Rechenzentrum.
Okay.
Second- and Third-Level-Support für den IT-Service.
Okay. Was suchen die?
Eine Admin. Okay.
Gewährleistung eines störungsarmen Betriebs.
Klingt für Admins auch sehr sinnvoll.
Konfiguration, Administrationsweiterentwicklung. Alles klar.
Steuerung von externen Dienstleistern.
...
Je nachdem, wie viel Anteil
das einnimmt, kann das nervig sein.
...
Warum?
Warum schreiben die immer so ein Bullshit dahin?
...
Das ist so die Wildcard. Wir halten uns das mal offen.
Nein, ihr sucht keinen fucking Projektleiter. Ihr sucht einen Admin.
...
Wenn er sich in die Richtung
weiterentwickeln will, schön und gut,
kann man für sich entscheiden.
Aber das ist aus meiner Sicht nichts für die
Stellenanzeige.
Teilnahme an vergüteter
Rufbereitschaft.
Natürlich sehr interessant. Wie vergütet?
Das bringst du mit
mehrjährige Erfahrungen.
Berufserfahrung
in der Administration von
Session-Border-Controllern.
Zum Beispiel Audiocodes.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist halt auch nichts
für mich. Second-Level-Support.
ACD
IVR-Lösung unter
Microsoft Teams. Kein Plan.
...
Ja, das klingt doch schon mal ganz okay.
Moderne Unternehmenszentrale.
Höhenverstellbare
Tische. Neueste Technik.
Restaurant. Das sind tatsächlich mal
Vorteile. Die finde ich gut, dass die drinnen stehen.
Unser Dialogikum
...
ist die eigene verantwortung blablabla mitgesteigte entwicklung mitarbeiter
rabatt jobrat waren sehr viele mittlerweile leasing urlaubs
weihnachtsgeld sowie betriebliche altersvorsorge übrigens chat ich bin
richtig dumm gewesen ich habe doch die ganze zeit schon
erzählt ich überlege mir ernsthaft noch bevor ich 40 wäre in die private
krankenversicherung zu gehen und ich habe die ganze zeit erzählt wo soll ich
dann hingehen und also gesundheitsprüfungen und alles und ich
bin nicht groß krank oder so falls ich denke was gedanken macht keine sorge ich
hab ich hab nix ich hab nix ich habe ein paar kilo zu viel immer noch trotz
trotz regelmäßigen kilometerlangem geränne aber alles noch nicht weg
zumindest letztens ist mir aufgefallen ich arbeite doch bei einer versicherung
und
so eine versicherung hat auch krankenversicherung und habe ich immer
schlau gemacht es gibt spezielle konditionen für
mitarbeiter krankenversicherung die unter anderem irgend so ein großer
gemeinschaftstarif sind ohne gesundheitsprüfung sie würden mich auch
todkrank nehmen was ich glücklicherweise nicht bin und ich hoffe nie werde
ich weiß nicht warum ich da jetzt irgendwie ein jahr für gebraucht habe
um zu checken dass wenn man bei einer versicherung arbeitet man dort
vielleicht auch eine versicherung abschließen könnte was passiert wenn du
die firma verlässt es bleibt das war mit der anderen altersvorsorge auch so
also dass jetzt zwar was anderes ich kenne den vertrag nicht aber ich bin
mir zu 99 prozent sicher das bleibt ja bock habe ich da auch nicht drauf aber
Aber ich werde mir das angucken, weil das ist nice.
Das gibt es billiger, keine Gesundheitsprüfung.
Das werde ich machen.
Ja, also die Stellenanzeige finde ich okay.
Ich kann zu dem Themengebiet nichts sagen.
Ich finde das in Ordnung.
Das ist zwar immer noch sehr 0815 alles.
Aber das liest sich jetzt nicht schlecht oder so.
Ziemlich Standard kostet die Stellenanzeige.
Und ich kann es nur immer wieder betonen.
Diese Stellenanzeigen ist denen immer der erste Eindruck, den wir von dem jeweiligen Laden bekommen.
Das sagt nichts darüber aus, wie gut oder schlecht dann wirklich unterm Strich die Arbeit dort ist.
Also wir haben hier bestimmt auch schon richtig miese Stellenanzeigen gehabt, wo coole Jobs dahinter stecken.
Aber das kann man ja nicht beurteilen.
Genauso wenig, wie die das bei eurer Bewerbung beurteilen können.
Die sehen nur das.
Was ihr denen da hinterlegt.
Wir gucken uns jetzt nochmal an.
Was macht ein Administrator bei dm-tech?
Was? Moment.
Nein, nein, keine Weep-Musik.
Wir sind sozusagen dafür verantwortlich, dass das VPN funktioniert.
Dass man morgens an seinen Rechner kann und sich einwählen kann.
Und in den Verteilzentren können wir sozusagen die WLAN-Ausstattung und die Firewalls konfigurieren.
Und für...
Aha, aha.
War das ein Packet Tracer?
Bei Packet Tracer hat es eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Ne.
Was ist denn das?
Es ist nicht Cakti.
Irgendjemand eine Ahnung?
Irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das ist?
Die hat Edge und Chrome auf ihrem Mac.
Ja, warum nicht?
Irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das ist?
Das ist bestimmt irgendein internes Knowledge Base System.
Ich meine, von der Farbe her könnte es Confluence sein.
Aber es sieht nicht wirklich...
Hä?
Vielleicht ist es auch Confluence.
Ist das das Draw.io Plugin für Confluence?
Für jegliche Netzwerksicherheitsthemen eigentlich.
Wir sind für Software-Deployment.
Das haben die immer so gerne in diesen...
Jegliche Netzwerksicherheitsthemen.
Ja, wie soll man sagen?
In diesen Image-Filmchen.
Dass dort Leute vor irgendeinem Patch-Panel stehen und an irgendein Kabel fassen oder irgendein Kabel reinstecken.
Oder sowas.
Vielleicht denken die, dass das symbolisiert für viele Leute IT, so.
Wir sind für Software-Deployment.
Aber guck mal, guck mal, die hat das eigentlich nur, die hat da eigentlich nur drangegriffen für das Video und hat nichts damit gemacht.
Windows-Clients, morgen KS, Alter.
Wir sind verantwortlich.
Wir kümmern uns um die Android- und iOS-Geräte bei DM Tech.
Da haben wir ein paar Zehntausend.
Davon und schauen halt, dass die einfach reibungslos funktionieren.
Da muss ich kurz drüber nachdenken.
Administration ist bei DM Tech...
Zehntausend?
Das ist zehntausend Mobilgeräte?
Da brauchst du schon ein eigenes Team, was sich da drum kümmert.
Dem Endkunden eine lauffähige Arbeitsumgebung zu schaffen, dass er arbeiten kann, ohne dass es Probleme gibt, dass er sicher arbeitet.
Aha, aha, Moment, Moment.
Vor Element in?
Was bin ich da sehend?
Irgendwelches Python Zeug, weil Einrückungsstelle, oder?
Mit dem Doppelpunkt für die Vorschleife...
Ja.
Irgendwelches Python Zeug bin ich da am sehenden.
Replace ETH....
Das beginnt damit, dass wir selbst...
Boah, ist der agil, häh?
Auch Software-Pakete stricken, mit PowerShell oder wir bauen auch selbst MSI's.
Weil man muss dazu erwähnen, dass es bei DM...
auch viel selbstentwickelte Software gibt oder Software, an denen noch einiges
konfiguriert werden muss, das machen wir dann alles.
Jeder in dem Aufgabengebiet, wo er ist, hat eine unglaubliche Gestaltungsmöglichkeit.
Das heißt, es kommt jetzt nicht von oben irgendjemand, wo sagt, hey, euer Produkt muss
jetzt in die Richtung XY weiterentwickelt werden, sondern es passiert bei uns im Team.
Das halte ich für ein Gerücht, dass da keine Vorgaben gibt.
Wie soll das sonst funktionieren?
Und können es dann auch entsprechend entwickeln und vorantreiben.
Und das ist einfach schön, dass man weiß, okay, ich kann hier neue Sachen entwickeln.
Ich betrachte immer die ganze Kette.
Wenn ich jetzt einen Mitarbeiter bei uns, sei es im Büro oder in der Filiale, eben
ermittle.
Ich ermögliche, dass er mit seinem Gerät so arbeiten kann, wie er es vielleicht auch
von zu Hause gewohnt ist, da er nicht viele Einschränkungen hat, nicht viel Zeit investieren
muss, weil irgendwas nicht funktioniert, dann ist dieser Kollege auch happy.
Wisst ihr, was das Beste wäre für die Leute, wenn die was haben wollen, was einfach funktioniert?
Keine Windows-Clients.
Okay, ich weiß, das ist nicht praktikabel für den 0815-Office-Snoop.
Ich meine ja nur.
Happy.
Was mich besonders freut, wenn ich in einem DM-Markt quasi drin bin und ich sehe,
die verwenden die Smartphones.
Also da freue ich mich jedes Mal wie so ein kleines Kind.
Das habe ich installiert.
Ich sehe, dass das, was ich jetzt hier im Büro oder im Homeoffice mache und ich quasi da vor meinem Rechner sitze,
dass die das verwenden können.
Gute Frage, was wir haben.
Warum filmt man hinter der Kamera?
Weil das viel dynamischer dann aussieht.
Das macht Spaß, Kaffee trinken mit meinen Kollegen.
Es ist schon ein bisschen bescheuert, die Kamera da hinzustellen und dann dahinter mit dem Handy rumzufilmen.
Aber das ist garantiert, weil das viel dynamischer wirkt.
Kaffee trinken mit meinen Kollegen.
Linux-Server scheint es da nicht zu geben.
Was mir am meisten Spaß macht, ist tatsächlich eigentlich schon so der Firewall-Bereich.
Also das mache ich am liebsten.
Wir haben im Team schon einmal im Monat einen sogenannten Automatisierungstag.
Wo wir uns neue Lösungen für unser Produkt überlegen.
Das ist ein Tag nur Brainstorming.
Und da kommen wir dann eben hier ins Dialogikum in die neuen Arbeitsflächen.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, was das sein soll.
Okay.
Ja, da kann man schöne Post-its und so überall hinpappen.
Arbeitsflächen und können da eben zusammensitzen und Lösungen neu entwickeln, abseits vom normalen Schreibtisch.
Ich kann mir vieles selbst einteilen.
Welche Projekte ich jetzt als nächstes machen gehe.
So was gibt es bei mir auch, dort wo ich arbeite.
Ich habe den Fehler gemacht, mal auf einem Meeting zu sehr nachzufragen, was sie machen.
Und da wollten die gleich, dass ich da mal vorbeikomme.
Bei uns nennt sich das, glaube ich, Innovation.
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas mit Innovation, IT-Innovation oder sowas.
Ich möchte sehen, welche vielleicht noch Zukunftsmusik sind oder nicht so eine hohe Priorität haben.
Das sind Vertrauen.
Und eben auch dieses Zutrauen.
Ja, okay, bla bla.
Also, ich meine, kein schlechter DM-IT-Image-Film, oder?
Ich meine, da habe ich schon Schlimmeres gesehen.
Ja, ich habe mal den Fehler gemacht, auf irgendeiner Runde war jemand von diesen IT-Innovation-Leute da.
Und ich habe die, ich weiß gar nicht mal was, ich habe die irgendwie was gefragt.
Und genau, nee, ich weiß nicht mal, was ich gefragt habe.
Zumindest meinte die dann, oh.
Ja, irgendwie cool, dass du schreibst, aus deinem Team ist ja dann noch gar keiner dabei.
Und ich habe gesagt, ja, ähm, klingt ja, dann habe ich den Fehler gemacht, ja, klingt ja nicht schlecht.
Und dann hat die gleich meinen Chef angeschrieben, so nach dem Motto, oh, der Max könnte sich vorstellen, bei IT-Innovation mitzumachen.
Richtig super, äh, schnell ging das.
Aber ich habe dann mich nicht mehr gemeldet und mache das jetzt auch nicht.
Kein Bock.
Ich habe keine Zeit dafür.
Eigentlich hätte ich ja prinzipiell schon Bock.
Aber bei uns sind IT-Innovationen eher so, nicht wirklich IT-Innovationen, sondern wie können wir irgendwas Technisches schön dem Vorstand oder irgendeinem Manager präsentieren.
Und da habe ich nicht so wirklich Bock drauf.
Ja, so zum Beispiel, oh, guck mal, bei Google gibt es jetzt die Möglichkeit, Kubernetes Autopilot.
Cluster anzulegen.
Wollen wir das benutzen?
Ja, ist ja cool, okay.
Dann lass uns das mal irgendeinem Typ vorstellen, der das mitentscheidet.
Und dann musst du dann irgendwie auf Manager-Ebene erklären, warum ein Autopilot-Cluster nice ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da Bock drauf habe.
Nee, nee, eher nicht.
Wie war eigentlich das Mitarbeitergespräch?
Kurz, kurz unknackig, da war nicht viel.
Wegen mehr Geld gehe ich den auch erst noch auf den Keks, wenn ich ein Jahr da bin.
Aber ich habe meinem Chef schon gesagt, also, ich verschone ihn jetzt noch, aber ab April nerve ich ihn dann öfters.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich halte ganz gerne Präsentationen, das habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Aber so rein, also, so ganz super abstrakte Sachen für irgendwelche rein BWL-Leute, da habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf, ja.
Wie viele Twitch-Emotes hast du im Mitarbeitergespräch verwendet?
Also bewusst keins.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass ich keine verwendet habe.
Also ich habe, letztens habe ich mich erwischt im Bad, da habe ich vor dem Spiegel gestanden, ich glaube, ich habe mich rasiert, ich habe nicht Zähne geputzt, ich habe mich, ich habe mich rasiert, nee, kann nicht sein, dass ich mich rasiert habe.
Da habe ich Zähne geputzt, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß noch, ich stand im Bad, vor dem Spiegel und hatte das Handy an und da lief irgendwas, ich glaube sogar Radio lief da einfach nur.
Ja, irgendein, irgendein Radio-Stream.
Auf dem Handy und da lief Werbung und das war irgendwie so eine total, total bescheuerte Werbung für irgendeinen lokalen Handwerkerbetrieb oder sowas.
Zumindest ist vollkommen egal, was das war.
Die Werbung war dumm und ich stehe vor dem Spiegel im Bad und sage Keckel, anstatt zu lachen darüber.
Also es kann bei mir ernsthaft passieren, dass ich sinnlos Twitch-Emotes verwende, wo andere Leute halt das Normale machen.
Wofür man eigentlich die Emotes verwendet.
Ich habe wirklich zu mir selbst im Bad in den Spiegel gesagt, Keckel, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Also so bescheuert ist das schon, so weit, so weit ist das bei mir schon.
Und dann nicht Kekke-W oder Lull, nein, wirklich Keckel.
Was ausgesprochen auch total beknackt klingt.
Nice.
Und unterm Strich gibt es dann trotzdem wieder genug Bonus.
Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt nichts vergessen von dem, was ihr geschickt habt.
Glaube aber nicht.
Ich war übrigens diese Woche schon in der Waffenverbotszone.
Muss ich die Woche nicht mehr hin.
Bahnstreik.
Wann ist denn das?
Wann ist denn wieder was?
Moment, das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt Verdi.
Warum hast du eigentlich keinen Masternode, weil da keiner ist?
Jetzt kannst du sagen, ja, aber wenn da keiner hingeht, wird da auch nie jemand sein.
Das ist mir egal.
Ich gehe da erst hin, wenn da ordentlich Leute sind.
Geht es da jetzt nur um Straßenbahn?
Oder auch Bahnbahnen, DB-Bahnen?
Montag bis Samstag?
Nö, ich nehme nicht das Auto.
Ich fahre dann einfach gar nicht die Woche nach Frankfurt.
Ey, ich fahre einfach nicht nach Frankfurt.
Ich mache da ganz normal Homeoffice.
Da sind die relativ, ja, flexibel, was die Planung angeht.
Wenn ich sage, hier, Streik, ich bleibe die Woche mal komplett daheim,
dann sagen die, jo, mach, passt.
Und selbst wenn ich drei Wochen am Stück,
die ganze Zeit daheim bleiben würde,
es wird wahrscheinlich keinen jucken,
solange ich im Durchschnitt ungefähr halt auf das komme,
was abgemacht ist.
Und ich bin sogar aktuell ein bisschen über dem Schnitt,
weil ich zum Beispiel vorletzte Woche,
glaube ich, sogar zwei Tage die Woche in Frankfurt war.
Drei Tage die Woche Homeoffice, ja.
Also ich habe standardmäßig drei Tage die Woche.
Also ich arbeite vier Tage die Woche,
drei Tage die Woche davon Homeoffice.
Einen Tag fahre ich nach Frankfurt.
Und mein Chef sagt, wir sollen halt gucken,
dass wir im Durchschnitt einen Tag die Woche da sind.
Und da bin ich sogar ein bisschen über dem Schnitt.
Warum fährst du nicht mit dem Rad zur Arbeit?
Du wohnst doch in der Nähe.
Naja, also mit dem Fahrrad sind es 28 Kilometer.
Einfach.
Es braucht schon ein bisschen.
Also da bist du schon Stunde 15, Stunde 20 oder so unterwegs,
wenn du nicht komplett geschwitzt sein willst.
Und es ist auch kein gutes Wetter zum Fahrradfahren.
Aktuell dazu kommt mein Fahrrad ist kaputt beziehungsweise nicht mehr straßentauglich.
Ich brauche ein neues und da habe ich mir noch keins gekauft.
Wenn schon, werde ich das machen, wenn es ein bisschen wärmer ist und dann aber auch nicht hin und zurück,
sondern nur zurück.
Ich nehme das Fahrrad einfach mit, stelle es bei uns in den Fahrrad Parkraum.
Wir haben da so einen extra Raum, dass nichts geklaut wird und dann fahre ich mittags zurück von
Frankfurt aus.
Mache ich einen schönen Schlenker, mache ich einen schönen Bogen, kann ich zwischen 30 und 40 Kilometer
kann man einen schönen Schlenker machen.
Kann ich fahren, bin ich zwei Stunden unterwegs, je nachdem wie groß die Runde wird.
Das ist eine schöne Runde dann, wenn es warm ist draußen und es lang hell ist, fahre ich mittags los, haue ich irgendwie
genau, haue ich 15 Uhr ab.
Oder so in Frankfurt, bin ich 17 Uhr daheim.
Schöne Runde, ja, aber dazu brauche ich erst mal ein neues Fahrrad.
Gab es Geld von der Versicherung?
Noch nicht, immer noch nicht, aber ich hätte mir auch so schon eins gekauft wieder.
Es ist leider gerade bei Rosenix lieferbar und ich hätte gern wieder gleichen Rahmen, den ich jetzt habe, weil ich mich da so dran gewöhnt habe.
Normales, kein E-Bike.
Zum Strampeln.
Ich habe heute wieder gestrampelt auf meinem Smart-Trainer, 45 Minuten im Durchschnitt, 175 Watt.
Also mein Ziel ist es ja, in nächster Zeit, dass ich es schaffe, auf Swift die 2,0, nee, nicht die 2,0, die 2,2 ist es glaube ich, die 2,2, also dass ich die 2,0 easy, oder was heißt easy, dass ich die 2,0
fahren kann, ohne dass ich komplett weg bin.
Dass ich komplett im Arsch bin, also 2 Watt pro Kilogramm fahren kann, ohne dass ich komplett im Arsch bin und dass ich mit wirklich Anstrengung auch die 2,2 Watt pro Kilogramm Swift-Runden ordentlich fahren kann, dann bin ich zufrieden.
Das ist für einen Einsteiger echt okay, muss man sagen.
Also finde ich.
Äh.
Ich habe den Vorteil.
Ja.
Ich bewege mich ja schon.
Ich habe schon seit den letzten Jahren verhältnismäßig viel im Vergleich zu früher und angefangen zu rennen, habe ich ja auch schon vor einer Weile, bevor ich jetzt noch zusätzlich angefangen habe mit Fahrradfahren, das heißt ein bisschen Vorarbeit habe ich ja geleistet.
Also ich bin zwar übelster Einsteiger, was Fahrradfahren angeht, aber so ein bisschen was an Ausdauer habe ich im Vorfeld schon gehabt.
Also die schnellsten 5 Kilometer, die ich bisher gerannt sind.
Ja gut, können wir ausrechnen.
Waren im Durchschnitt 5 Minuten 22 pro Kilometer.
Das mal 5.
Quickmuffs, Leute.
Irgendwas um 26 Minuten oder so, hä?
Also irgendwie 26 Minuten für 5 Kilometer.
Das war das schnellste, was ich bisher gerannt bin.
Da muss ich aber sagen, da war ich auch sehr im Arsch danach.
Und habe instant, nachdem 5,01 auf meiner Uhr standen, gestoppt.
Und dann habe ich mich auch sehr im Arsch danach.
Und bin erstmal langsam gelaufen und musste schnaufen, ey.
Also da war ich echt fertig.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das jetzt aktuell schaffe.
Weil über Weihnachten habe ich ein bisschen abgebaut wieder.
Aber ich denke, in dem Dreh kriege ich immer noch hin.
Alles klar.
So Leute, ich muss jetzt pennen.
22.15 Uhr.
Wir sehen uns die Tage, vielleicht morgen schon.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.